Ich glaube, du verklärst die Vergangenheit. Ich glaube, was du brauchst, ist erstmal so ein Node.js mit einem...
Das heißt der gewerbliche Anschluss dann für das, was ich jetzt, das Gigabit, ich meine du kriegst ja in den meisten Gegenden jetzt auch Gigabit, wenn du willst, koste ich halt irgendwie 3k im Monat oder so. Das ist Gigabit so. Das heißt für die 3k wird man dann zukünftig einen Terabit kriegen und für die keine Ahnung unter 100 Euro dann deine 10 Gigabit nach Hause. Das ist so jetzt meine Vorstellung und da bin ich im Moment am sammeln, wie man das denn jetzt am besten umgesetzt.
Und das ist jetzt erstmal, ich meine die Phase ist ja eine Sache. Wie sieht es dann mit den Daten darüber aus? Sind die dann auch irgendwie flat oder ist da wieder delimited irgendwann? Verstehe und aber ich meine, dass die Telekom uns jetzt hier abzocken will, dem würde Clemens ja irgendwie zustimmen, dass die Preise da schon sehr stark so reguliert und auch designt sind, dass man halt oder die Produkte, die sein sind, dass sie da gut Geld verdienen. Aber ich meine, am Ende musst du ja auch als Stadtwerk, als Terabit-Firma Kabel verlegen, Daten einkaufen und das Geld muss ja auch irgendwo reinkommen. Die Stadt Berlin will es ja sicher nicht zahlen, oder?
Klar, muss ich am Ende des Tages natürlich rechnen.
Aber wo ist denn der Unterschied zu irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen?
Bei kommunalen Unternehmen kannst du natürlich erstmal, also die Kommune hat natürlich das Wegerecht. Das ist so die, also wie gesagt, wir haben am Anfang gesagt, so das Paketangebot, so alles, also Gas, Strom, Wasser, Internet aus einer Hand, das ist schon mal so eine Überlegung. Und wie gesagt, wie man das Modell dann konkret ausgestaltet, so, wer die Fasern dann am Ende des Tages beleuchtet und so, das ist, also da sind wir noch nicht, sind wir jetzt noch nicht, also es gibt jetzt noch kein detailliertes Konzept, sondern wir haben jetzt gerade angefangen.
Oder geht es darum, dass ihr erstmal die letzte Meile macht, dass aus der letzten Meile wird eine durchsichtige, nämlich eine Glasmeile und dann können die Anbieter kommen und können sagen, hier, wir würden gerne eure letzte Meile versorgen und dann können sie sich darum bieten.
Das ist mir erstmal komplett wumper, Hauptsache, da kommen 10 Gigabit an. Wie ist mir völlig scheißegal oder ist das Terabit? Wie das am Ende funktioniert, wie gesagt, ist…
Weil es jetzt auch erstmal nur die physikalische Verbindung ist und wie viel Internet du dann darüber erhältst, ist das nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Okay, es geht nur um den Tausch erstmal, die letzte Meile sozusagen aus den Händen der großen…
Also wenn die Großen das hinkriegen, soll es mir auch ehrgefallen sein. Also mir geht es, wie gesagt, mir geht es halt jetzt nur darum zu sagen, okay, wir wollen Mittel und Wege finden, halt, ich meine, wenn die in Singapur es offensichtlich hinkriegen, da ein Gigabit den Leuten heute in die Wohnung zu legen, dann was spricht dagegen? Also warum sollte das nicht in Berlin gehen, in fünf Jahren 10 Gigabit den Leuten in die Bude zu legen? Also man muss nur wollen. So, und ja, das ist, und da versuche ich jetzt einfach nur zu gucken, okay, was kann jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren noch anschieben, ich meine, es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, auf wem Wege der Volksgesetz gehen und kannst, wenn du dann genug Unterschriften zusammenbringst, kannst du halt auch ein Gesetz hier durchbringen, wo die Leute sagen, wir wollen 10 Gigabit Internetversorgung haben.
Hast du denn den Eindruck, dass zumindest jetzt in der Berliner Politik das als Problem angesehen und verstanden wird, wenn man jetzt sagt, jeder soll einen Gigabit zu Hause haben? Also meine Erfahrung ist ja immer, da gucken alle erstmal an wie so ein Pferd, so nach dem Butterjagd, wieso denn?
Genau. Das ist eher, ist aber nicht nur in der Politik, sondern du wirst es halt auch generell wahrscheinlich hören. Wozu denn? Es ist ja, weil es gibt halt Studien, die sagen, okay, selbst hier bei VDSL, wenn du die Leute fragst, greifen 80% zu langsameren im Internet als VDSL, denen reichen dann ihre, die brauchen eine 50, die nehmen dann halt lieber, also 80% nehmen halt 16 Megabit oder 10 Megabit und halt nicht, da gibt es doch dieses schöne Zitat, was glaube ich Henry Ford in den Mund gelegt wird.
Wenn ich die Leute gefragt hätte, was sie wollen, hätten sie gesagt, schnellere Pferde. Und das ist genau die Antwort, die du gibst, schnellere Pferde.
Der Punkt ist tatsächlich noch, braucht man das überhaupt, aber ich will das, ich halte deswegen.
Du hast ja auch total recht, meine Würste haben wir nicht gehört, aber wer gerade mit Clemens mit dir vorstellen kann, haben wir hier häufiger ähnliche Debatten. Er berichtet dann auch mal ganz gerne so aus dem gelobten Land, das ist in dem Fall Schweden. Die es ja nicht nur schafften, den Leuten in der Stadt ein Gigabit hinzulegen, sondern wo sozusagen auch noch wirklich das entlegenste Dorf in Nordschweden, wo wirklich so die Bevölkerungsdichte so niedrig ist, dass sie es jetzt gar nicht in Zahlen ausgerückt bekommen. Vielleicht auf eine Person, ein Gehöft auf einen Quadratkilometer, wahrscheinlich sogar weniger. Und ja, da wird die Strippe dann halt einfach hingezogen. Und wenn die Strippe dann da liegt, dann kommt dann überhaupt erst das Angebot. Dann kannst du einfach auswählen, dann kannst du auch jederzeit wählen, welchen Provider du jetzt haben willst. Also auch so im Hinblick auf Netzneutralität natürlich ein offenes Netz. Und ich finde es auch absolut absurd, dass es nicht schon lange auch eine gesetzliche Verpflichtung gibt, dass wenn irgendwo in Berlin die Straße geöffnet wird, nicht automatisch ein Glasfaserkabel der Stadt reingeschmissen wird und verlegt wird, weil das einfach dann die Bedingung dafür ist.
Ja, das ist alles, die Realität ist halt unendlich kompliziert. So wie gesagt, also beziehungsweise nicht Realität, sondern das, was wir daraus gemacht haben, also im Bereich jetzt der Energiepolitik. Ich meine, ich habe da jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren so die ganzen Gesetze und Verordnungen und wie das mit der Energie ist und so und da kannst du nicht nur Bücher, da kannst du Bibliotheken mitfüllen mit dem Statusquo und so mit Leitungen verhindern. Ja, aber die eine Leitung, die hält halt 40 Jahre, die andere hält halt 80 Jahre, da kann es ja nicht dann nach 40 Jahren irgendwie schon, wenn die eine Leitung durch ist, nicht, also die andere hält ja noch. Also mit solchen Debatten hast du es dann zu tun. Aber egal, die Idee war jetzt quasi nochmal zu gucken, was kann man tun, weil gerade schon, also eigentlich wollen das alle auch, also es gibt ja niemanden jetzt in der Stadt, der sagen würde oder keine Partei, nein, es soll auf gar keinen Fall 10 Gigabit Anschlüsse geben oder nein, wollen wir nicht oder nein, es ist scheiße, sondern eigentlich finden das grundsätzlich irgendwie alle gut. Die Schwierigkeit ist natürlich, das jetzt tatsächlich hinzubekommen und Politik ist halt, dass du halt versuchst, erstmal alle möglichen Akteure dann zusammenzubringen und an einen Tisch zu holen und irgendwie einen Weg zu finden und dann mit Gesetzen und Geld und so. Ich meine, in Berlin, wir verteilen halt schon als Parlament jedes Jahr 23 Milliarden Euro in der Stadt. Das ist schon bis, also ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht, dass wir die jetzt frei verteilen, aber so der Haushalt sind halt 23 Milliarden so und das ist ordentlich Geld und da ist auch ein bisschen Spielraum da. Also da kann man schon mal Dinge machen und so, also ja, also da kann man auch schon mal für eine Milliarde oder zwei irgendwie investieren.
Würde man zumindest machen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich würde man sogar, also es gibt irgendwie, habe ich die Zahl gehört, um überall einmal so komplett Fiber hinzulegen, würde Deutschland weit 100 Milliarden kosten. So, wenn man das jetzt auf Berlin umrechnet, wird es wahrscheinlich weniger, ist wahrscheinlich mit zwei Milliarden oder so, kann man wahrscheinlich, kriegt man das alles komplett hin. So, was da und das ist jetzt nicht so viel Geld.
Dann hätten wir hier auch einen Wirtschaftsstandort.
Ja, dann hätten wir gesagt, dann kämen halt die Firmen hierher, weil es hier halt einfach das schnellste Internet der Welt gibt, so für Firmen und ich meine, dann, ja, das wäre wirklich.
Das ist auch ein echtes Argument für Start-up.
Ja, das wäre wirklich, genau.
Also ich kenne auch eine Menge kleinere Firmen vor allem, die einfach das Problem haben, dass sie entweder bestimmte Stadtteile komplett ausschließen müssen oder für die einfach Berlin einfach überhaupt keine Aktion ist, weil man einfach davon ausgehen muss, dass man hier einfach keine zukunftsfähigen Netzverbindungen hinbekommt. Das ist schon echt traurig.
Gerade in Deutschland Infrastrukturland.
So, also das ist, wie gesagt, so ein Ding, mühsam, aber so, ja, das versuche ich halt jetzt noch irgendwie ein bisschen mit anzuschieben in den letzten, ja, nicht mehr ganz zwei Jahren. Wobei wahrscheinlich noch ein Jahr oder so. Demnächst ist wieder Wahlkampf. Da kann man sowieso nichts mehr machen. Also das letzte Jahr der Legislaturperiode passiert nichts mehr. Alle Wahlkampf.
Ich würde jetzt gerne mal ein neues Thema aufmachen.
Ja, machen wir ein neues Thema auf.
Ich war mal wieder shoppen. Und zwar, Huckel hat ja letztes Mal berichtet über anstehende Thunderbolt-Audiointerfaces. So dass man jetzt quasi über diesen PCI-Express-Bus, der Thunderbolt ja letzten Endes ist, mit diesen Audiogeräten kommunizieren kann. Was ja an sich schon mal eine ganz gute Idee ist. Also richtig professionell ausgestatteter Mac Pro hatte früher ja auch oder teilweise auch heute noch, steckt man ja auch in eine Audiokarte direkt in den Slot rein. Warum? Einfach damit man die Bandbreite hat, um viele Kanäle zu machen, aber vor allem um eine niedrige Latenz zu haben. Und da Thunderbolt nichts anderes ist als ein PCI-Express-Bus, extern bietet sich das natürlich an, nur gab es da halt irgendwie nichts. Und Huckel hat letztes Mal diese neuen Devices von Focusrite vorgestellt oder bzw. erzählt, dass die jetzt kommen, diese Clarett-Teile. Problem war nur, ich hab dann mal geguckt, irgendwie die gibt's ja noch gar nicht. Also weder gibt's da ordentlich Preise für, noch sind die irgendwie lieferbar. Und als ich dann so rumklickte, stellte ich fest, es gibt von Moto, Moto hieß irgendwann mal Mark of the Unicorn, bis sie sich Moto genannt haben.
Ach die heißen jetzt, stimmt, sie haben auch das Einhorn aus dem Logo verschwinden lassen.
Jaja, eigentlich schade, ne? Moto ist ja auch so eine Bude, die irgendwie ganz ordentliche 7-Zoll- und 19-Zoll-Hardware macht. Und ich hab auch schon so das eine oder andere Moto-Device benutzt. Die sind da irgendwie ganz pfiffig. Und sie waren eigentlich auch immer ganz vorne dabei, was so Interfaces betrifft. Aber mir fehlt dann ganz schön was aus dem Gesicht, als ich festgestellt habe, dass ihre neue Generation nicht nur Thunderbolt hat, sondern darüber hinaus auch AVB.
Was ist AVB, muss ich jetzt fragen, ne?
Genau, was ist AVB? AVB, ich hatte das hier auch schon ein paar Mal angedeutet, dass es sowas gibt oder geben wird. AVB steht für Audio-Video-Bridging und ist der IEEE-Standard für Audio über Ethernet. Jetzt ist ja so, ich verwende...
Das hast du sozusagen schon hast hier.
Nee, also naja, ich habe schon Audio über Ethernet.
Aber nicht nach Standard.
Nicht nach einem IEEE-Standard. Genau genommen, was ich hier habe, ist Audio über IP. Weil, also was ich hier habe, ist Dante. Das ist das Produkt von der Firma oder der Protokoll-Standard von der Firma Ordinate. Und Ordinate, australisches Unternehmen...
Das, was immer nicht funktioniert hatte, ja?
Doch, doch, das funktioniert eigentlich super.
Man hat noch mal voll lange Ärger damit, oder nicht?
Ich habe immer noch Ärger. Aber das Problem war... Also ich kann das nicht hundertprozentig sagen, aber das Hauptproblem, warum es mal so richtig katastrophal war, war, dass mein Switch kaputt war. Und wenn natürlich ein Switch die Daten nicht richtig weiterleitet, dann ist es kein Wunder, dass so eine Realtime-Dienstleistung dann auch mal ausfällt. Aber das war jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne ein Problem des Protokolls. Ich habe auch noch Restprobleme, wo es etwas schwierig ist zu sagen, woran es jetzt genau liegt. Aber das lasse ich jetzt auch mal außen vor. Tatsache ist, dass diese Audionet-Geschichte schon sehr gut funktioniert. Das lässt sich allein daran erkennen, dass es sich einfach im Markt rasant durchsetzt. Also es gibt extrem viele Hersteller, die Dante-kompatible Interfaces in ihre Geräte einbauen. Und jeder größere Hersteller hat mittlerweile irgendwie sowas im Angebot, vor allem im Pro-Bereich. Und es spricht ja auch einiges für Dante. Also vor allem, weil sie relativ geringe Anforderungen an die zur Runde liegende Netzwerkinfrastruktur haben. Also wenn du mit Dante Audio über Netzwerk leiten musst, brauchst du erstmal kein separates Netz. Du kannst das nur um alle und selbe Netz nehmen, wo du halt auch sonst deinen IP-Verkehr drüber fährst. Und du hast auch keine speziellen Anforderungen an deine Switches, weil das alles über Layer 3 geht. Die einzige Voraussetzung ist, der Switch darf natürlich jetzt nicht kaputt sein. Aber es muss halt mindestens Gigabit Ethernet sein. Und es geht nur auf Gigabit Ethernet. Jetzt gibt es aber schon seit längerem halt diesen IEEE AVB-Standard, der ja über viele, viele, viele Jahre hin entwickelt worden ist und der jetzt im letzten Jahr dann auch mal seinen Segen bekommen hat. Dann dauerte es allerdings so ein bisschen mit Produkten. Und ich dachte schon, das passiert jetzt irgendwie überhaupt nicht, weil als erstes kam die Ankündigung von Cisco, dass sie das irgendwie nicht in ihre Switches einbauen wollen, warum auch immer. Da dachte ich schon so, oh, oh, kommt das jetzt überhaupt noch? Und jetzt gibt es halt solche Devices. Der Unterschied zwischen AVB...
Was heißt, die wollen das nicht in ihre Switch einbauen? Ich denke, da gibt es keine speziellen Anforderungen an die Switches.
Bei AVB schon.
Ach so.
Genau, das wollte ich nämlich jetzt gerade erläutern. Dante brauchen nur schnell und funktioniert sozusagen. Macht aber alles über IP. Das heißt, sie haben kein Ethernet-spezifisches Ding. Sie erwarten nur ein Netz, das mindestens die Geschwindigkeit von Gigabit Ethernet hat. Also de facto läuft es nur auf Gigabit Ethernet, weil es gibt ja in dem Sinne überhaupt nichts anderes. AVB wiederum ist definiert auf Layer 2 vom Ethernet. Das heißt, das ist eine richtige Low-Level-Audio- und Videotransmission, die explizit auf 802.1 oder 802.11 kompatiblen Netzwerkstrecken läuft. Das schließt im Übrigen WLAN mit ein. AVB ist auch definiert für WLAN. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es mindestens erfordert, entweder N oder AC. Und es geht auch theoretisch mit Fast-Internet. AVB könnte auch funktionieren auf 100 Megabit.
Ja, das heißt, die haben da......
könnte, de facto sind wir...
Parallel zu IP, was eigenes.
Genau, das Offlayer 2 ist sozusagen unabhängig von IP. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass du halt erstmal nicht IP benutzen kannst, um zu routen und dass du quasi in deinem Ethernet-Netzwerk so eine eigene AVB-Domäne sich ausbreiten musst. Also die Verbreitung deines Ausstrahlungsbereichs hängt dann eben von diesen Switches ab. Wenn du keinen AVB-kompatiblen Switch hast, kommst du über diesen Switch mit AVB nicht hinaus. Das AVB bleibt immer auf einer Collision Domain. Und wenn du halt möchtest, dass zwei Geräte miteinander AVB, Audio miteinander oder auch Video austauschen, dann musst du einfach einen AVB-kompatiblen Switch haben. Also einen Switch, der explizit dieses AVB-Protokoll unterstützt. Ja, ich meine, Cisco saß natürlich wie alle anderen da mit in diesen Gremien und hat diesen Standard mitdefiniert. Also ohne Cisco wäre da auch nichts gelaufen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie nie damit rauskommen werden. Es war nur so, als der Standard fertig war, haben sie gesagt, dass sie das jetzt nicht bei Default in alle ihre Switches einbauen.
Kannst du das erinnerst du dich auch so ein bisschen? Geil, wir machen jetzt mal so ein bisschen so einen komischen Standard, so parallel zur IP, damit wir irgendwie noch mal dick Hardware verkaufen können. Deswegen sagt Cisco auch ja, ne, wir rüsten das nicht in dem Zeug nach, was wir schon haben, sondern da gibt es halt extra Geräte für.
Na gut, Cisco ist eh nicht im IP-Business so richtig. Also sind wir im Switch-Business. Ist schon voll ihre Domäne. Und ich rechne auch damit, dass sie das tun werden. Nur ihre erster Move war halt erstmal zu sagen, dass sie es erstmal nicht tun werden. Klar, weil es jetzt auch erstmal keinen Markt gibt. Das ist halt ein Henne-Eye-Problem an dieser Stelle. Und das scheint sich jetzt zumindest dahingehend zu lösen. Was heißt lösen? Zumindest ist es jetzt soweit, dass Hersteller AVB-Equipment raustun. Und keiner scheint so sehr darauf zu setzen wie Motu. Das ist zumindest jetzt mein Eindruck. Weil sie haben mal locker 10 neue Devices vorgestellt, die halt alle mit AVB daherkommen. Also das ist jetzt nicht so...
Wo von einer ein Switch ist.
Genau, wo von einer ein Switch ist. Das müssen sie jetzt im Prinzip alle auch raustun. Ein 5-Port-Switch ist halt so ein kleiner Tisch-Switch, mit dem du halt deine REC oder deine Devices miteinander verbinden kannst.
Und was kann das jetzt, was der IP-Kram nicht kann?
Ja, eigentlich nichts. Nur, dass es sich hier um einen offenen IEEE-Standard handelt. Und man kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, ob Layer 2 oder eher Layer 3 der richtige Ort ist, um das abzufackeln. Da spricht für beides irgendetwas. So ist nun mal AVB definiert. Aber du hast halt zumindest Autodiscovery und solche Sachen. Und ich sage das jetzt alles mit der Einschränkung. Also ich habe mir jetzt so ein Moto 8M gekauft. Weil das für mich attraktivste Gerät aus dieser Reihe ist. Allerdings, ich habe es heute gerade mal ausgepackt. Also ich habe das noch nicht angeschlossen und habe noch nicht gesehen, was Sache ist. Ich vermute auch mal, dass man hier so oder so noch mal Treiber installieren muss, um irgendwie den ganzen Kontrollchannel zu haben. Aber die AVB-Audio-Support ist in Mac OS X schon seit 10, 8 Jahren drin. Das heißt, meine Erwartung ist, dass selbst wenn ich keine Treiber installiere, das werde ich dann nächstes Mal berichten.
Nochmal, also AVB ist in Mac OS 10, 8 Jahren schon drin? Also schon vor zwei Jahren?
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Wie ist es mit der Host-Unterstützung für den Standard?
Ich habe es noch nicht überprüft, aber meine Erwartung ist, und das hat mir auch Thomas gesagt, du schließt das Teil an. Und das ist halt so, als wenn du ein USB-Audio-Device anschließt.
Das ist nochmal langsam. Du steckst dein Gerät einfach ans Netz. Für deinen Rechner ist da ein neues Audio-Device da.
Da ist dann das AVB-Audio-Device.
Und dann noch mal langsamer. Du schließt das jetzt hier an. Und auf welchen von den vielen Rechnern kommt das neue Audio-Device? Auf allen?
Auf jedem, der in dieser AVB-Switch-Domain ist und das Ding sieht. Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt direkt mit einem Kabel in meinen Mac Pro reinstecke, dann sieht der Mac Pro das.
Und wenn du es an deinen Switch ansteckst, der das sagen wir mal jetzt könnte...
Ja, wenn ich das an einen Switch anschließe, der keinen hat, dann passiert da einfach mal gar nichts.
Da bleibt was da stecken. Das sind doch höchstwahrscheinlich nur die Management-Switches, die da nicht per Default AVB durchlassen. So ein ganz Dummer, der einfach alles durchschiebt, was Ethernet ist.
Nein, nein, nein, die Switche müssen das explizit annoucen. Die müssen explizit sagen, hier ist ein AVB und auf diesem Port ist jetzt auch AVB. Und das muss sich dadurch sozusagen verbreitern. Das heißt, du bleibst automatisch in deiner kleinen Wolke stecken, wenn du nicht explizit weitergereicht wirst. Und deswegen brauchst du eben diese AVB-Switches, um mehr als ein Device anzuschließen. Es sollte aber ausreichen, und das ist das, worauf ich jetzt setze, dass ich das Gerät halt direkt an meinen iMac oder direkt an meinen Mac Pro anschließe.
Weil du dann sowieso zum Beispiel zweimal Ethernet hast, da hast du einen e-Frei oder du könntest auch da dauernd WLAN benutzen, wenn du denn Dante da noch dran hast. Und bumm, dann ist er da. Ist sozusagen wie so ein USB-Fireware-Kabel, sozusagen jetzt das Ethernet-Stecker, zack.
Genau, und er sagt dann, hier ist ein Device und das funktioniert so.
Hast du aber noch nicht gemacht.
Hab ich noch nicht gemacht?
Na, er hat es hier live ausgepackt und rangesteckt.
Ja, dann fängt dann die Sendung an, da war ich gerade kurz davor. Ich habe auch noch ein paar andere Sachen zu tun. Ich werde das nächste Mal berichten. Die Geräte, die Mutto da ausgerollt hat, sehen auch alle sehr interessant aus. Also sehr vielfältig, kleine Teile, große Teile, Switches, mit irgendwie allem möglichen Kram. Also im Prinzip haben sie alles gemacht. Und vor allem sie haben auch in allem Thunderbolt. Deswegen war ich mir jetzt relativ sicher, dass ich das Gerät haben wollen würde, weil selbst wenn das mit dem Ethernet irgendwie nicht so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle, dann habe ich auf jeden Fall noch die Option Thunderbolt. Denn was ich ja eigentlich machen will, ist, ein sehr latenzarmes Gerät zu betreiben als Audiointerface, wo ich meine Mikrofone anschließen kann, bzw. meine Headsets anschließen kann, was ja noch viel wichtiger ist, und das ganze Mixing in Software zu machen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen der heilige Gral eigentlich, so beim Audio-Recording. Weil derzeit, wenn ich das halt jetzt tun würde, mit einem normalen USB-Interface oder so, da ist dann die Latenz in der Regel einfach schlecht. Ich weiß, jetzt kommen gleich wieder alle aus ihren Büschen gesprungen und sagen, ja, aber mit RME und da und da und da ist das ja angeblich auch alles schon so super ultra-low latency und haste nicht gesehen. Ich habe das bisher noch nicht nachvollziehen können. Also mir ist das bisher so noch nicht aufgefallen. Stimmt schon, RME ist niedrig. Nur wie niedrig so eine Latenz wirklich wahrgenommen wird, das hängt auch extrem von der einzelnen Person ab. Ich persönlich habe gemerkt, dass ich super anfällig bin für Latenzschwankungen. Also ich drehe...
Latenzschwankungen oder?
Na ja, okay, du hast recht, nicht Schwankungen, sondern hohe Latenzzeiten. So. Ohne dass ich das jetzt konkretisieren kann. Vier Millisekunde ist dann vorbei.
Bevor ich es wieder vergesse, hatten wir vor der Sendung ganz kurz die Diskussion. Jetzt ist mir wieder aufgefallen, immer vor wegen schnelles Internet, bzw. schnelles Netz, ich mir jetzt diesen neuen Mac zugelegt habe und auch irgendwie einen neuen WLAN-Access-Point. Und ich plötzlich festgestellt habe, dass ich über WLAN jetzt 1300 Megabit, also 1,3 Gigabit habe. Mit welchem WLAN-Access-Point? Ich habe einen von so einem ASUS, eine komplizierte Zahl, drei Antennen. Jedenfalls habe ich mir dann überlegt, wenn jetzt mein WLAN so schnell ist, brauche ich eigentlich, hätte ich dann gerne in meiner Wohnung, also ich habe ja Glück überall in der Wohnung, wo eine Steckdose ist, habe ich halt auch eine Ethernet-Dose. Und dachte mir, eigentlich müsste ich dann jetzt so lokal mein Netz auf 10 Gigabit zu Hause aufrüsten, damit es was bringt, wenn ich mich dann noch irgendwie in die Dose stöpse. Und habe dann mal geguckt, wie weit denn jetzt, was es denn da für zu Hause an 10 Gigabit-Technologien gibt. Und da würde sich vor allem halt dieser 10-G-Base-T, heißt der, glaube ich, das ist halt 10 Gigabit Ethernet über normale RJ65 und Twisted Pair. RJ45, genau. Ja, so. Und dann war aber das genau das Problem, weil du gerade sagtest, okay, wie kriege ich jetzt aber hier an meinem nagelneuen Mac, wie kriege ich hier jetzt da 10 Gigabit Ethernet irgendwo dran? Und da wurde es dann tatsächlich irgendwie schwierig. So, ich habe zwar dieses Thunderbolt und ich glaube, das kann auch, ja. Ja, doch, den hatte ich auch, da war irgendein Haken dran. So genau, fürs Laptop war der nicht so direkt.
Ich denke mal, dass der so die Führerppen so drum rum hat, hat schon seinen Sinn.
Also es gibt von Sonnet Tech einen 10 Gigabit Ethernet, Thunderbolt, Interface.
Kannst du bitte mal den Preis googeln? Ich würde mal sagen, der geht in Richtung vierstellig, oder?
Ah, weiß ich nicht, mal gucken.
Haben die denn noch in den Rektorhäuser eingeladen?
Aber die ganzen Kühlrippen da dran, die machen einen schon.
Ja, die sind schon komisch, aber die Switches war jetzt, ich glaube, es gibt aber 12-Port-Switches jetzt schon für unter 2000 Euro, also mit 12, 10 Gigabit, 10G, Base-T, so und also das war quasi für mich jetzt gerade einer von sagen, was gibt es denn schickes für Thunderbolt. Ich will mir ein, dass irgendwie...
Guck mal, 600 Dollar.
Ja, also und es gibt auch hier bisher Express-Karten und so, die liegen, glaube ich, bei 400, genau, da hast du irgendwo eine und aber es ist schon noch ein bisschen... Teuer. Ein bisschen teurer als...
Ja, bisschen teurer als ein Gigabit. Ja, nee, ist noch nicht wirklich die Zeit gekommen. Da müssen wir noch warten, bis die 10 Gigabit-Internet einfach mehr oder weniger aus so einem kleinen Mini-Adapter rauskommen, so wie es jetzt aus dem Gigabit-Adapter auch rauskommt.
Genau, und ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum...
Was du davon abhalten solltest.
Ja, gut, ich hab mir auch gesagt, ich warte jetzt noch mal ein bisschen ab, aber eigentlich wäre es Zeit, jetzt langsam zu Hause schon mal ins Auge zu fassen, wann man denn auf 10 Gigabit...
Brauchst du noch einen Rechner, der in der Lage ist, die Datenmengen dann auch von der Platte zu kratzen und über das Netz zu drücken und auf eine Platte auch wieder draufzuschreiben? Ich meine, wir reden hier von einem Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Ja, die SSDs sind ja inzwischen, wenn man sie richtig als PCI einbaut, habe ich ja schon erzählt, sind bei 1,4 Gigabyte die Sekunde.
Also die schaffen das gerade so.
Nee, besser, 10 Gigabit sind ja 1 Gigabyte die Sekunde. Und die SSDs sind schon schneller, wenn du eine PCI-Karte so in Gut hast.
Ja, also sie schaffen das gerade so in ihrer Netto-Datenrate, in ihrer Botodatenrate sozusagen. Was für ein Netto dann übrig bleibt aus Falltransfer, ist da nochmal eine andere Frage. Da muss man auch das Fallsystem und der Rechner irgendwie performen. Gut, mag alles möglich sein, aber das dachte ich halt bei Gigabit am Anfang auch, hat auch eine Weile gedauert, bis die Maschinen dann wirklich so performt haben. Es ist auch entsprechend gebrummter, da muss ja auch das Betriebssystem mitspielen.
Naja, gut, aber hat dann halt im Moment…
Ja, aber mit was willst du denn auch zu Hause reden? Also dein Mac muss ja mit irgendeinem anderen Gerät reden. Das müsste ja dann auch 10 Gigabit haben. Hast du einen dicken Fileserver zu Hause oder willst du einen haben oder was? Oder willst du mit dem anderen Laptop in der Küche mit 10 Gigabit irgendwas machen? Ja, ich merke schon. Aber Pavel, du willst jetzt die zwei Milliarden hier im Berliner Haushalt nicht verbraten, weil du gerne einfach nur 10 Gigabit hättest.
Nein, nein, das war eher genau umgekehrt, dass ich halt mir dachte, okay, wenn ich das jetzt haben will, dann will ich das sozusagen in ein paar Jahren, dann will ich schon mal gucken, wie nächstes zu Hause genau was...
Wenn das dann kommt, damit...
Was kann ich denn damit machen? Wie geil ist denn das jetzt wirklich so? Und ja, wie gesagt, schnelle Backups, dann ansonsten, ja, keine Ahnung. Eigentlich braucht es kein Mensch, aber...
Das Ding ist doch, Technik wird doch immer so lange schneller, bis die Zeit, die irgendeine Sache braucht, für den Menschen eigentlich nicht mehr wahrnehmbar ist. Und ich glaube, das war so eine halbe bis viertel Sekunde, oder wo war das, wo das für den Mensch eigentlich instant ist, oder? War das nicht so?
Ja, also, ich meine, gut, wenn du jetzt wirklich, also zum Beispiel Filme ist ja noch nicht... Also, wenn du jetzt irgendwie so 4K-Filme mit einer ordentlichen Bitrate und so, das dauert halt schon mehrere Minuten, die...
Warte, Pavel. Du lädst Filme irgendwohin? Du lädst Filme irgendwohin?
Ja, du nicht?
Was machst du?
Ich starte einfach, egal wo in meiner Bude liegt der Film. Ich mounte das und mach Doppelklick und dann legt der los.
Ah, das ist nicht...
Weißt du, was der große Augenblick war, wo ich wusste, alles wird gut werden? Ich glaube, das war sogar bei Pixelpark. Da musste irgendwie eine CD brennen und dann machst du die auf den Rechner und drückst und brennst und toast und weißt und wisst schon. Und irgendwie war aber das Image auf einem File-Server. Die Rohlenken waren noch teuer damals. Da ich die aber nicht bezahlen musste, sondern wahrscheinlich halt Pixelpark, wenn es da war, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, dachte mir, eigentlich kann ich jetzt mal testen, ob ich einfach dieses Image, ich kopiere das gar nicht rüber und brenne es dann, sondern ich mache das direkt vom File-Server und das wird schon irgendwie gut gehen. Und das ging gut. Und da wusste ich, das ist die Zukunft. Man muss gar nicht mehr alles da haben. Und mit Filmen ist doch eigentlich genau das Gleiche.
Und das ist ja alles schon 15 Jahre her jetzt.
Du brauchst den Film doch gar nicht auf deinem Rechner. Du hast gesagt, du hast hier AC WLAN, 1,3 Gigabit. Und dann willst du den Film noch zu den kopieren? Ich meine, der ist von über dem WLAN doch fast schneller als von deiner SSD da. Ja, nicht ganz, aber...
Du musst sie ja dann irgendwie da drauf kriegen, zum Beispiel. Und wie gesagt, allein Backups. Und wie gesagt, an sich gibt er ja recht, braucht eigentlich kein Mensch, aber... Ich will halt gucken, was man dann damit machen kann.
Zum Beispiel auch, wenn die Filmindustrie mit ihren Filmen angeboten, also wie mit den iTunes-Filmen, die machen es ja schon mit dem Livestream. Aber jetzt ist es ja so, wir wollen auch VDSL und Gigabit-Internet haben, weil wir laden halt erst den Film runter und gucken den dann. Das heißt, ich muss da irgendwie ein, zwei, drei Stunden warten, bis es da ist und fange dann an zu gucken. Wenn die Angebote aber besser werden, dann bräuchte man ja fast gar nicht so viel Internet, weil ich klick einfach den Film direkt, weil der Stream, der kommt ja die ganze Zeit rein, während ich den Film gucke. Und dann, das sind ja, was sind das? Das sind vielleicht, das sind keine 10 Megabyte.
Nee, aber ich kenne ein besseres Beispiel, wenn du mal ein modernes Spiel, sag ich mal, gekauft hast, so über Steam, dann sind die in der Regel jetzt so groß wie eine Blu-ray. Auch wenn du die über Steam kust. Ich kann dir sagen, so bei 25 Gig.
World of Warcraft ist bei über 30, glaube ich, inzwischen.
Über die Jahre gewachsen. Jetzt installieren wir das mal. Und dann, zwei Tage später, kannst du anfangen.
Aber die guten Spielehersteller und die bei WoW machen das inzwischen so, weil 30 Gig ist wirklich ein bisschen viel, die haben so einen Downloader, der fängt schon an, lädt dir deine Anfangswelt runter, wo du dich erst mal aufhalten wirst, wenn du in der Welt sozusagen da geboren wirst. Und dann kannst du schon mal loslegen, dann merkst du, dass er im Hintergrund schon andere Sachen runterlädt. Und dann sagt er dir aber auch, du hast jetzt schon so ein bisschen da, wenn du aber jetzt andere Gegend betreten willst, dann müssen wir erst weiter runterladen. Das heißt, der kann schon so teilweise deine Welt so zusammenladen. Das heißt, das sieht auch schon so nach so einer…
Ja, aber nicht jedes Spiel funktioniert so.
Nee, nee, ist schon klar, das muss man halt so designen. Aber so fangen die halt schon an, das zu tun.
Ja, klingt scheiße.
Also ja, also besser… Und der liegt im Hintergrund weiter. Es ist nicht so, dass alles über das Netz kommt, sondern der cached schon mal…
Ja, wenn du jetzt so langsames Internet hast, ist das natürlich hilfreich. Aber besser ist halt… Wenn du es für ein gutes, also besser ist halt, bei unserem 10 Gigabit würde das trotzdem noch dauern. Dieses 25 Gigabyte Spiel würde dann trotzdem noch eine halbe Minute dauern. Ich glaube, das würde ich dann akzeptieren. Gut, da kann man schon mit leben. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, bis es… Das eigentlich Interessante ist ja, was man halt machen kann, wenn das Internet so schnell ist.
Die Ideen kommen erst dann, wenn man es hat.
Genau, und wir wollten ja, dass genau diese Ideen Leute in Berlin haben und nicht woanders.
Damit ich vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Idee habe, habe ich halt überlegt, ob ich mir halt jetzt nicht zuhause wie gesagt auf 10 Gigabit einfach mal hoch gehe. Also stimmt schon, es ist dann halt wieder so, ja man ist da ein bisschen an der Grenze. Auf der anderen Seite, ah es gibt natürlich noch eine andere Anwendung, wenn man irgendwie Software entwickelt, wofür du das dann brauchst. Das ist zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt so die private Anwendung, aber wenn du halt einen Server hast, lasst Tests simulieren. Das ist halt schon wichtig, also zum Beispiel bei Hocker war es halt so, dass wir halt wissen wollten, naja gut, was passiert denn da? Also bei Hocker haben wir halt da hier in Richtung Spandau so einen Rack stehen, da haben wir halt 10 Gigabit, aber für den Server. Und dann wollten wir mal gucken, okay, wie viele Clients können sich denn jetzt mit dem Server tatsächlich verbinden? Und haben es dann auf 700.000 gleichzeitig Verbindungen gebracht, aber die eigentliche Schwierigkeit war dann, 700.000 Clients zu simulieren. Ich glaube, wir haben uns irgendwie 60 virtuelle Maschinen, also 60 große virtuelle Maschinen, so die größten VMs, die man sich irgendwie im Netz klicken kann. Bei Domain Factory übrigens, Jiffy Boxen, da haben wir sehr gute Erfahrungen mit gemacht. Weil da kannst du dir die Dinger schnell mal eben für auch relativ wenig Geld im Vergleich zu Amazon oder so, haben die halt eine viel interessante Tarifstruktur. Dann hast du halt so 60 fette Maschinen, die dann versuchen, so auf deinen Server einzudreschen. Wenn du dann endlich deine 10 Gigabit kannst, kannst du halt auch zu Hause deine eigenen Dienste betreiben. So für die Welt. Du kannst dann halt mal eben ein paar Hunderttausend oder ein paar Millionen Leute von zu Hause aus mit irgendwelchen Services versorgen.
Zumindest dann, wenn dein Provider dir genauso viel Up wie Down gibt.
Ja, der Trend geht auf jeden Fall in die Richtung.
Also die Meta-Ebene, die gefüllt ihr Gigabit schon mal, der Download-Server, wenn er nach Frage ist.
Und würdest du den Server zu Hause hinstellen, wenn du zehn Gigabit hättest?
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich überhaupt einen Server woanders benutzen sollte, wenn ich das von zu Hause aus machen könnte.
Weil du so eine laute Kiste zu stehen hast?
Das muss ja nicht laut sein.
Also das ist nämlich, wie gesagt, der andere, der Freiheitsaspekt. Dann brauche ich halt die Server nicht irgendwie von irgendwelchen amerikanischen Firmen betreiben zu lassen, sondern dann...
Ja, was auch teuer ist und was auch irgendwie Beschlagnahmeprobleme hat und was ist, wenn es nicht läuft und man erreicht da keinen. Also klar, man spricht eine ganze Menge dafür, sowas zu nutzen, aber spricht halt manchmal auch einiges dafür, sowas selber zu machen. Na gut, ich denke, es ist ein bisschen sinnlos darüber zu diskutieren, ob man sowas braucht oder nicht. Mit dem Brauchen ist das sowieso immer so eine Sache. Und vor allem, mehr Netz heißt ja auch, man kriegt einfach mehr Anwendung. Wollen wir nochmal zurückkommen auf das Audio? Also gut, im Prinzip ist ja eigentlich alles gesagt. Interessant, ich werde das mal ausprobieren mit dem AVB, wie das so funktioniert und ob das vor allem so funktioniert, wie ich mir das so vorstelle. Ziel der ganzen Sache ist, so ein Setup zu bauen, so ein Studio-Setup zu bauen, wo ich halt nicht von dem Wiring eines Mixers, wie derzeit, abhängig bin, um diese ganzen Verschaltungen zu machen, sondern wo ich quasi so ein flexibles Podcast-Studio aufbauen kann, durch reines Software-Routing. Das wollte ich eigentlich schon immer. Das heißt, in der Software all diese Mixer machen, die man halt braucht. Also allein jetzt hier, während wir hier sitzen, fünf Leute, haben wir schon mal fünf Mixer für die Kopfhörer. Ein Mix für den Stream. Und im Prinzip noch mal ein für das Recording. Das ist dann mehr oder weniger der gleiche. Weil man will die halt unter Umständen auch alle separat regeln. Die Kopfhörer haben alle separate Lautstärken. Man schaltet auch mal ein Mikrofon aus, etc., Bestimmte Sachen kann ich derzeit halt überhaupt nicht machen, wie zum Beispiel, was ich ja liebend gerne mal tun würde, gerade hier mit den Remotes, die wir hier benutzen. Und derzeit halt hier nur für die Rospa-Taste so eine Backchannel-Geschichte zu machen. Also ich würd gerne so auf der V-Mode eine Taste drücken. Und wenn ich die Taste drücke, dann rede ich halt und höre ich halt den Backchannel. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mit einem von euch während der restlichen Sendung gehe...
Das lenkt bestimmt überhaupt gar nicht ab.
Na, es lenkt sehr viel mehr ab, wenn ihr entweder eure Kopfhörer runterreißt oder einfach diese ganze Sache im Frontchannel macht. Ja. Ja, also das ist ja genau der Punkt. Man kann ja sehr leise miteinander reden. Das stört eigentlich nicht groß. Und ich kann ja mal leise reden, während ich mein Mikrofon ausschalte. Ja, hat das gestört?
Du musst den Chat fragen.
Also es geht schon. Aber mir fiel gerade nur auf, dass ich glaube jedes Mal, wenn ich bei dir war, Tim, hattest du ein komplett anderes Podcast-Equipment. Ich kann mich nie erinnern. Also im Abstand von innerhalb eines Jahres.
Das ist langsamer geworden. Letztes Jahr ist es relativ stabil.
Ich kenne nichts von dem, was hier jetzt gerade steht.
Du warst aber auch sehr lange nicht mehr da.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal vor zwei Jahren oder so war ich hier drin. Vielleicht vor drei Jahren. Ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren. Da erkenne ich nichts von wieder hier.
Ja, das ist... Ja, also mit... Ja, den Mixer gab es ja schon. Na, wie auch immer. Das muss ich ja auch alles weiterentwickeln. Ich will ja dann auch letzten Endes irgendwie mehr. Ja, wobei Mixer ist halt auch Sicherheit. Also der schafft schon Vertrauen und das ist eine enorme Stabilität. Deswegen nutze ich jetzt meine Zeit in England, um mir da sozusagen ein lokales Studio da selber zu bauen. Weil ich brauch ja quasi eh nochmal ein zweites Studio, ein kleines. Und das mache ich dann halt mit diesem Motto.
Soweit...
Bilde ich mir das jetzt zumindest gerade ein. Und dann werden wir mal schauen, was da rauskommt.
Das ist die Idee hier.
Aber ich finde, die sind gedacht, ein Software heute zu machen.
Ihr hört dann Tim nächste Sendung fürchterlich fluchen.
Bestimmt.
Aber der Sound ist schon sehr gut, muss man sagen. Hier auch auf den Ohren. Und es klingt irgendwie ziemlich geil. Schon, ja. Ich mach ja schon so... Also gelegentlich mit dem einen oder anderen Podcasts gut mit. Also Maha schleppt mich halt gerne mal irgendwie in seinen... Gut, der hat ja auch teilweise tragbaren Kram und so. Aber kein Vergleich. Ja, wie lange geht denn das eigentlich jetzt noch? Was haben wir denn noch für Themen?
Wir haben gerade angefangen.
Das geht so bis... Wir haben erst später angefangen. Heute wegen dir, Pavel, bis eins wahrscheinlich.
Da muss ja zwischendurch eine rauchen gehen.
Na mal gucken, wir haben ja eigentlich gar keine Themen.
Also normalerweise fangen wir um 20 Uhr an und machen so bis 12.
Ich hab noch mal einen Nachtrag zu Thunderbolt, weil ich hab ja dann mit der Aussicht an die Audiohardware jetzt mit Thunderbolt rangehen zu müssen. Und ich hab ja... Mein einziger Mac mit Thunderbolt ist ja mein R. Also mein Mac Pro und mein iMac haben das alle noch nicht. Deswegen auch meine Hoffnung auf AVB, dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert. Dann hätte ich da mehr Zugang. Aber so oder so hätte ich ja dann immer noch meinen R. Das Problem ist jetzt nur, das Gerät hat halt nur einen einzigen Thunderbolt-Ausgang. Und den brauch ich ja auch noch für Internet. Also ich brauch den für Internet, weil ich will halt Internet machen. Ich stehe einfach auf Kabel. Na ja, da dachte ich mir so, hm, da gibt es doch diese tollen Thunderbolt-Docs. Da schließt man sich dann an und so. Ja, in der Tat, das würde mein Problem auch insofern lösen. Also es gibt da von Elgato gibt es eins, es gibt von Belkin eins, und dann gibt es noch so ein paar komische Noname-Teile, die ja immerhin dann so Gigabit-Ethernet direkt in diesem Doc haben. Aber du musst dich ja mit diesem Teil auch selber mit Thunderbolt verbinden. Und ich finde es bemerkenswert, dass die alle dann nur einen weiteren Thunderbolt-Ausgang haben.
Ja, weil du, glaube ich, auch nicht so viel chainen kannst.
Wie? Man kann nicht so viel chainen?
Also du kannst chainen, aber du kannst, glaube ich, keinen Hub bauen oder so. Also du kannst ja nicht aus einem Thunderbolt zwei Thunderbolts machen oder irgendwie sowas.
Man kann nur daisy chainen, ja.
Wieso soll man das nicht können?
Weil das Protokoll das nicht vorsieht? Hast du das mal mit SCI damals gemacht?
Bei PCI geht das aber eigentlich.
Das ist PCI, das sind irgendwie PCI-Express-Lanes.
Ja genau, wie viele Lanes hat denn so ein Thunderbolt?
Gute Frage, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Bin mir auch nicht so sicher.
Na Apple unterscheidet ja zwischen Thunderbolt und Thunderbolt 2.
Da ist wiederum, also ich hab mir neulich mal...
Das sind aber gleich viele Lanes.
Ich hab mir neulich mal tatsächlich den PCI-Express-Standard angeguckt, wie das denn ist. Weil ich wollte wissen, wenn ich jetzt nicht nur 10 Gigabit, sondern wenn ich halt mehr 40 oder 100 Gigabit haben will, wo ist denn jetzt das Ende eigentlich von...
Da muss man erst mal gucken, wie schnell der PCI gerade überhaupt ist.
Genau, wie schnell die sind. Und da gibt es halt einmal die Lanes-Geschichte. Ich glaube, das geht bis 32 Lanes, aber ich glaube, es gibt nur 16. Also spezifiziert ist es bis 32, dann gibt es irgendwie vier verschiedene Taktraten. Also da gibt es den Standard und dann zwei, vier, achtfach, glaube ich, gibt es dann noch.
Ja, das sind PCIe 1, 2 und 3, oder?
Ja, genau, und vier gibt es jetzt demnächst.
Genau, das sind die Taktraten dann, richtig? Genau, die kriegen dann nämlich ein bisschen mehr dann drüber, weil die dann irgendwie wie viel Bits die auch pro Byte brauchen und so. Und bei PCIe 3 ist halt, die machen das halt in größeren Blöcken und dadurch geht ein bisschen weniger Overhead drauf.
Ja, und die haben teilweise unterschiedliche Modulationsverfahren, wie auch auf dem, dann was sie da auf der seriellen Schnittstelle machen und so. Aber da ist im Moment auch, also weiß gar nicht, ich glaube bei 16 oder 32 Gigabit ist glaube ich jetzt auch Schluss bei PCI-X im Moment.
Kann man ja mal gucken, also hier 32 Lanes sind hier noch eingeklammert, weil es die wahrscheinlich noch nicht wirklich gibt. 16 gibt es aber und bei PCI 3 machen die so knappe 16 Gigabyte die Sekunde.
Fit.
Hier steht ein großes MB, ich denke mal es heißt Megabyte die Sekunde.
Ach, Megabyte, ich habe Giga verstanden.
Ja, Gigabyte habe ich ja gesagt. Also hier steht 15754 MB die Sekunde. Das sind knappe 16 Gigabyte die Sekunde.
Pro Lane oder für?
Ne, für alles zusammen.
Für alle 16.
Okay, ja, ich dachte jetzt. Ne, ne, für alles zusammen. Pro Lane ist natürlich relativ kleine Werte, aber...
Genau, also dann ein Gigabyte pro Sekunde pro Lane ungefähr?
Ja, 985 da oben steht es, ja, genau.
Also stimmt das ja mit dem, wie das...
Also sind das nur vier oder was?
Vier Lanes?
Bei Thunderding jetzt oder was? Thunderbolt-Lanes müsste ja schnell kommen hier.
Ja, aber das Ding hat ja zwei mal zehn Gigabit. Zwei und zwei Lanes raus. Wir kommen glaube ich ein bisschen durcheinander.
Thunderbolt-Port kann mit einem native Display-Port-Signal mit vier Lanes Output-Data, das ist nicht mehr als 5,8.
Ja, aber erklär mir mal, wie ich jetzt sozusagen ein Gigabit Ethernet... Ich meine, dieser Gigabit Ethernet-Port, der heute in diesem Dock ist, der geht ja auch letzten Endes von diesem Thunderbolt ab. Ich meine, das ist ja auch sozusagen... Der bedient ja den selben Port und auch einen HDMI-Ausgang, der da rausgeht. Die kann ich ja alle parallel betreiben. Dann müsste ich doch im Prinzip auch weitere Thunderbolt-Anschlüsse an diesem Dock haben können, an denen dann auch solche Sachen dranhängen. Die müssen ja nicht die volle Datenrate ziehen, wenn es halt voll ist, ist es halt voll. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe auch so gelesen, dass man die nur daisy-chain kann. Der kann ja sozusagen nur den, der schon da ist, weiterreichen, aber er kann ja den nicht zweimal weiterreichen.
Ja, aber mein Audiodevice hat ja nur einen. Wie schließe ich da noch ein Thunderbolt-Display an?
Na, du schließt das Audiogerät an dem Thunderbolt-Display an. Weil das hat ja das Daisy-Chain ja.
Also sieben Hops für irgendwie.
Überzeugt mich nicht.
Und du hast nur einen Thunderbolt an deinem Rechner, oder was?
Gibt es nicht sogar die großen Micro-Programme?
Pavel hat zwei jetzt hier.
Du hast zwei?
Ja, ich hab auch zwei.
Schmeiderei.
Ja, also Thunderbolt 1 sind…
Ach, das 13er Micro-Pro hat zwei Thunderbolt-Ausgänger?
Ich hab hier zwei Ausgänge.
So, und jeder Stecker hat zwei bidirektionale Kanäle von je 10 Gigabit.
Genau.
Also hast du sozusagen zwei Mal 10 Gigabit rein oder raus? Also bidirektional würde ich sagen.
Also bei Thunderbolt 2 konnte sozusagen beide Kanäle…
Zusammenfassen.
Nee, zusammenfassen, was bei dem normalen nicht ging. Da zählen die eine Richtung und zählen die andere Richtung.
Gut, also für Audio sollten da nicht 10 Gigabit eigentlich reichen?
Natürlich reicht das aus. Ich hab mich nur gewundert, dass ich an so einem Dock nicht noch irgendwie auch noch zusätzliche Thunderbolt-Anschlüsse bekomme. Davon ausgehend, dass es halt demnächst noch weitere Thunderbolt-Devices gibt, die man vielleicht anschließen möchte.
Ja. Also der Punkt ist, man kann die halt nur in Reihe schalten. Warum kann man die eigentlich nur in Reihe schalten?
Weil, ja warum eigentlich?
Wegen Bodennebe, was weiß ich.
Ich kauf mir wahrscheinlich trotzdem mal so ein Thunderbolt-Dock, weil dann hab ich zumindest mein Internet da schon mit dran. Und noch ein HD-Di-Ausgang.
Das ist doch beim Display, beim Thunderbolt-Display auch schon mit drin.
Ja, ich hab gar keinen Thunderbolt.
Und irgendwie in dem Stecker ist irgendwie noch ein Hochleistungskomputer verbaut, damit der halt die Signale ja irgendwie, angeblich 12 Chips braucht. Ein Thunderbolt-Adapter, damit der irgendwie... Also das ist schon...
Naja, ich mein, da geht auch wirklich ordentlich was drüber, oder? Weil 10 Gigabit irgendwie, dann noch mit in beide Richtungen, also der komplette PCI-Bus mit allem Schnickschnack. Was ich aber noch sagen wollte, ist, dass, auf welches Produkt ich warte, ist, dass sie eigentlich hier bei den Macs, also die haben ja auch immer noch hier diese, was haben die gerade für einen Chip, Haswell? Da ist ja der eingebaute Iris-Intel-Grafikstein drauf und dann die rechts unten Geräte haben ja immer noch dann AMD oder Nvidia Extra, Nvidia gerade ist es, ne? Als wo die fette Grafik ist. Und eigentlich will man doch ein Thunderbolt-Display, was halt angeschlossen wird, wo die Grafikkarte im Display ist, die ganz fette, da können sie dann auch ihre Kühlungen reinmachen und auch richtig fettes Ding verbauen, weil da kann ja gekühlt werden und da kommt auch ordentlich Strom und so. Und ich brauch das in meinem Laptop gar nicht, ich will das eigentlich über dieses Thunderbolt-Kabel.
So ein Doppelslot für Grafikkarte im Display drin haben.
Wie ein Doppelslot.
Naja, wo du dann deine Grafikkarte reinschrauben kannst.
Nein, die soll da natürlich fest verbaut sein, ich will da auch keine Grafikkarte mehr in mein Display einbauen. Aber dann könnte man sozusagen das normale Display kaufen mit der normalen Grafikkarte oder das Display mit der richtig fetten Grafikkarte. Und man muss es in seinem Rechner nicht mehr mit rumschleppen. Die sparen sich das da auf der Platine. Das können sie noch kleiner und noch flacher und noch energiesparer bauben.
Aber brauchst du nicht mehr PCI-Power? Brauchst du nicht mehr PCI-Bandbreite, um diese Grafikkarten auch wirklich zu versorgen? Also gerade diese Grafikkarten ziehen auch extra viele Lanes.
Ja, bei den Nerds ist es so, dass die mal sagen, ja, klar, wenn du so eine Grafikkarte kaufst, dann musst du natürlich in den PCI-Slot reinmachen, der die 16 Lanes hat und so, weil dann ist halt die Anwendung an den Speicher besonders schnell. Aber es hat sich auch rausgestellt, wenn du das nicht tust, dann verlierst du irgendwie so 5% deiner Frame-Rate bei so einem First-Person-Shoot. Also das ist nicht ganz so mega, mega dramatisch. Und was hat heute eine Grafikkarte, der hat 4 GB RAM, das wird auch von den meisten Spielen noch gar nicht so richtig genutzt. Die nächste Generation ist schon wieder bei 6 oder 8 GB. Also eigentlich ist das alles in der Grafikkarte mehr oder weniger sowieso schon drin an Texturen. Da muss gar nicht mehr so hardcore-mäßig viel übertragen werden, würde ich mal sagen. Also das geht schon. Das ist nicht die super High-End-Lösung, das ist schon klar. Aber ich würde mal denken, so was kommt irgendwann, dass die Grafikkarte ins Display wandert. Und der nächste Grund, warum das passiert ist, wie man ja beim iMac 5K gerade schon sieht, es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Standard, um 5K irgendwie über Kabel zu machen. Noch nicht, da soll zwar einer kommen, aber es dauert irgendwie alles noch. Und wenn das immer so weitergeht, auch demnächst, da reden wir nicht wieder von 8K-Bildschirmen, dann geht das nur, wenn die Grafikkarte direkt im Bildschirm sitzt, weil es da gar keine Schnittstellen für gibt. Das müssen die direkte anbauen und festmachen und ohne Stecker und Gerumpel, sondern direkt rein. Dann kannst du so eine hohe Auflösung fahren.
Ich bin nicht so richtig davon überzeugt, dass die Grafikkarte im Display der richtige Ansatz ist.
Du brauchst die fette Grafikkarte nicht unterwegs, sondern du willst sie natürlich wirklich im guten Display haben. Was du nur anstöpselst, wenn du sowieso in der Nähe dieses Displays bist. Also warum die Grafikkarte mit rumschleppen. Ich finde, seine Argumentation macht total Sinn.
Naja, was ist, wenn du deinen Rumschlepp-Rechner in ein anderes Bild anschließt?
Was ist denn? Dann hast du eine andere Grafik.
Dann musst du sie in dein Internet nehmen und dann ist es nicht so flott. Du hast halt Pech gehabt.
Ja, brauchst du einen Treiber dafür.
Aber wenn du woanders bist und mal schnell anschließen willst, dafür Powerpoint reicht auch die interne.
Alles, was man irgendwie mit sich rumschleppen muss, ist irgendwie kacke. Also alles, was irgendwie extra ist, nee. Also selbst, ich meine, so eine externe Festplatte oder so, das ist alles Mist. Hier so ein Adapter, gut, den brauchen wir nicht so oft, aber...
Ist auch Mist. Ja, ist eigentlich auch Mist.
Definitiv. Ich meine, ich habe mir auch eigentlich, vor zwei Monaten habe ich mir hier jetzt dieses Gerät gekauft, weil die Batterie bei meinem eigentlich noch...
Das ist jetzt ein, musst du dazu sagen.
Ach so, das ist jetzt so ein...
Das aktuelle 15 Zoll...
Ja, das ist irgendwie rechts unten Retina...
Das mit der guten Grafikkarte.
Ja, das mit der guten Grafikkarte und das mit 16 GB RAM und mit 1 TB SSD.
Was muss man da gerade so ablegen für?
Das war irgendwie, hatten die das im Sonderangebot...
Was für ein Sonderangebot?
Bei Cyberport hatten die das irgendwie...
Da haben sie sich ans Rangeholt und sind es nicht los geworden.
Ja, was habe ich denn dafür? 2,7, 2,8 oder so habe ich dafür hingelegt. Bei Apple hätte es 3,3 gekostet, glaube ich. Deswegen fand ich das schon nicht okay. Und es hat aber nicht so viel SSD wie mein schönes... Mein 17 Zoller, da ist halt die Batterie gestorben. Ich konnte es aber jetzt nicht abgeben. Bei Apple ist es halt, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist, und du willst es halt original... Du kriegst es halt nicht von einem Tag auf den anderen. Die Batterie war halt so gestorben, dass ich es die ganze Zeit am Strom haben musste. Wenn der nur gewackelt hat, dann ist halt das Gerät ausgegangen. Das war halt mein Hauptarbeitsgerät. Dann so Batterie wegbringen und so. Hier Apple. Es kam alles einschicken, nicht infragen. Dann habe ich bei Cyberport das Ding gesehen und dachte mir, dann hole ich mir halt was Neues. Aber mein 17 Zoll hatte eine 1 TB und eine 512 war SSD drin. Deswegen musste ich mich jetzt ein bisschen einschränken mit dem 1 TB. Aber ich habe jetzt die Batterie auch wieder ausgewechselt. Und dieser kleine Bildschirm sackt halt auch diese 15 Zoll.
Aber 17 Zoll, was ist denn das für ein Gerät? Das ist so wild.
Intel? Ja, mit i7, also hier im Prinzip. Genau, das Ding in 17.
Das letzte 17 Zoll halt. Und so höherer kennen sie sich da aus, glaube ich.
Genau, das was Hoccal hat.
Hat er doch jetzt nicht mehr. Hat er auch jetzt einen Special Non-Glossy, weißt schon.
15, der hat auch 15 jetzt.
Schon ewig hat der keinen 17 Zoll mehr.
Echt?
Non-Glossy? Hat er doch die Story erzählt, dass er extra noch irgendwie so einen Deal hat mit Graves auch. Oder der Graves war das letzte Non-Glossy. Und dann ist ihm noch Suppe reingelaufen oder irgendwas war. Und dann war er schon ganz traurig, aber es konnte gerettet werden. Weil es gibt es halt nicht mehr und er mag keinen Glossy.
Nein, 15.
17 Zoll hat er schon ewig nicht mehr. Hoccal ist kein Grafiker, man. Der ist jetzt voll Backendspezien und so weiter.
Genau.
Aber Pavel, wenn du auf so riesen Bildschirme stehst, was ich ja nicht immer verstehe, ich habe ja auch dieses 15 Zoll. Und ich habe aber eigentlich immer überall, wo ich gearbeitet habe und auch zu Hause habe ich das so gemacht. Ich komme nach Hause, stecke das an meinen riesen Display, wo schon entweder DVI und USB oder jetzt halt hier ein Mini-Display-Pod und USB und ich mache meinen Rechner mal zur Seite und habe da mein Display und meine Tastatur und arbeite da. Und dann habe ich den riesen Bildschirm und eine ordentliche Tastatur und nicht dieses Zeug hier unterwegs.
Ja, ich sitze ja die meiste Zeit, wenn ich programmiere, ich sitze überhaupt die meiste Zeit draußen.
Und dann Sonne?
Ja, also auf der Terrasse, die ist halt überdacht und so. Deswegen, jetzt ist es ein bisschen kalt, aber…
Ein bisschen, ja, muss man schon was drüber ziehen.
Genau, deswegen muss man sich ein bisschen dicker anziehen. Aber so war ich rauchhalt drin nicht. Deswegen sitze ich halt lieber draußen.
Da bist du aber wirklich im wahrsten Sinne ein Hardcore-Rauch, oder?
Ja, ich rauche da nicht so viel, aber ich finde es auch angenehm, an der frischen Luft zu sitzen, ins Grüne zu gucken. Das ist viel besser als drin. Und deswegen ist das halt, finde ich, auf dem Balkon mit so viel Technik, ab und zu baue ich da noch ein paar USB-Hubs und fünf Telefone und so. Aber das nervt dann schon ein bisschen. Das ist halt kein Stubenhocker.
Da kleppt man den 27-Zoll-Monitor jetzt nicht immer so mit.
Genau. Und ich bin es auch einfach gewohnt, da runter zu gucken. Ich kann das gar nicht mehr so nach oben gucken.
Nein, man soll ja nicht nach oben gucken. Die Oberkante des Bildschirms soll auf Augenhöhe sein. Das heißt, man guckt grundsätzlich runter, weil man ja zur Mitte des Bildschirms guckt.
Ja, und wie willst du das bei so einem 40-Zoll- oder 30-Zoll-Bildschirm machen?
Einen großen Bildschirm ist ja übertrieben. Kann man natürlich machen, aber... Ja gut, aber jeder hat so seine eigenen Dinger.
Angenehm ist es, es ist halt wirklich leicht. Also man merkt es echt auf dem Rücken, weil ich habe das Gerät halt immer dabei.
Nicht jetzt der 17 Zoll, sondern jetzt sind wir wieder bei dem neuen 15 Zoll. Es wiegt ja auch nur die Hälfte. Naja, nicht ganz.
Ne, aber das macht sich...
Das 17 Zoll war bei dreieinhalb Kilo, das hat 2,1 Kilo. Das kenne ich aus.
Aber, also meins war irgendwie extra heavy. Ich weiß auch nicht warum, aber... Also ich merke es jedenfalls deutlich, welches... Also welches von beiden Geräten man im Rucksack hat, kann man sehr deutlich unterscheiden, auch wenn da noch irgendwie der übliche andere Kram...
Ich kann mich ja nicht, ich hatte zwar nicht einen 17 Zoll, aber wir hatten ja beide ja damals, Tim, dieses 3400 oder wie hieß das?
2400C.
Genau, es wog ja auch dreieinhalb Kilo dieses Ding. Ein Monster.
Aber ich würde sofort irgendwie...
Ich war so froh, als ich es los war.
Ja, aber ich würde sofort einen Pfund oder auch ein Kilogewicht dafür hergeben, wenn ich hier halt die Rambau-Steine und die Platten austauschen könnte. Das ist wirklich irgendwie echt... Ja, dieses festgelötete Nerven.
Also ich sehe das ja, dass man da basteln will, aber ich meine, du hast doch die 16 GB drin. Du hast wirklich die Angst, dass eines Tages du brauchst 32 und du kannst nicht aufrüsten oder wie?
Na ja, gut, du hast natürlich bei den Intel-Chipsetzen hat man immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, die begrenzen das auch sehr gerne, was so die Oberkante an RAM ist, den man einbauen kann.
Nee, das sind aber nur die Specks, die das so machen, so wie bei irgendwelchen Atombords. Da haben die immer gesagt, da gehen nur vier Gigabyte rein. Mein Kumpel steckt da irgendwie Speicher rein, hat nicht genau geguckt, was es für Regeln sind. Er bootet uns ein FreeBees, die sagt, ja, da sind jetzt sechs Gigabyte drin. So was kann nicht sein. Intel sagt, da gehen nur vier rein. Und alle sagen, da gehen nur vier rein. Ja, so, aber hier, guck, geht doch. Dann stürzt es bestimmt ab, wenn wir gleich anfangen, den Speicher zu benutzen, dann haben wir alles vollgemacht, und da ist nichts abgestürzt. Das Ding hat einfach sechs, und wahrscheinlich hätten sogar acht funktioniert, hätte man die da reingesteckt. Also das macht Intel sehr gerne nur wenige angeben, wenn die wollen, dass du eigentlich deren Serverzeugs kaufst. Und Apple macht das ja auch so. Die geben ja nur die Größe an, die zum Verkauf der Markteinführung, die da gerade reingeben. Wenn dann später größere Chips kommen, dann ändern die da nichts dran. Das interessiert die irgendwie gar nicht.
Bevor sie den Scheiß hier eingelötet haben. Also meine Tochter, die hatte halt das erste MacBook Unibody Aluminium. Also bevor sie es in Pro umbenannt haben, gab es ja das MacBook Aluminium Unibody.
Ne, das MacBook kam gleich mit Pro, oder?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Also das kleine MacBook. Also ich meine jetzt das 13 Zoller, sorry. Das 13 Zoller Amp war ja das Weiße und dann haben sie halt, ja, so. Und das war was, 2009, 2008, 2007, jedenfalls schon etwas länger her. Ich glaube 2008 oder so war das und dann habe ich ihr vor, ja, vor anderthalb Jahren, glaube ich, habe ich ihr gezeigt, wie man das halt aufpampen kann. Hab ja halt so ein SSD zu Weihnachten geschenkt gekriegt, was sie sich dann einbauen durfte und ein bisschen RAM und so. Und dann noch jetzt für das neue Gerät genau so ein DVD. Hast du da eigentlich ein DVD-Laufwerk bei dir drin?
Nee, habe ich letztens ausgebaut.
Und ausgetauscht gegen eine zweite Platte?
Ich will doch kein drehendes Metall in meinem Rechner.
Nein, kannst du auch eine zweite SSD rein.
Ne, brauch ich nicht. Also da kannst du halt jetzt für zwei 1TB SSDs reintun. Ich habe hier 256 GB, komm da locker mit klar.
Ja klar, kann man machen.
Ich habe Fileserver, da liegt alles. Und ich klicke dann doppelt, ich lade mich mal auf, dann weißt du Pavel, ich mache das über ein Netz. Das ist schon deswegen ganz gut, weil ich muss nur 256 GB ins Backup reinschieben, weil so große Backup-Platten kann man sich ja gar nicht besorgen, dass du die letzten zehn Monate 2 TB als Backup hast.
Wie auch immer, um die Geschichte jetzt kurz zu Ende zu bringen, war das halt faszinierend, auch mit dem RAM ursprünglich konnten die nur 4 GB. Dann hat man aber festgestellt, dass sie plötzlich 8 GB auch können. Das heißt, mit der SSD und 8 GB Aufrüstung hatte meine Tochter nach fünf oder sechs Jahren, nachdem wir das Ding gekauft hatten, ein Gerät, was halt einfach mal so schnell war, wie alles, was man fünf oder sechs Jahre später so für wenig Geld kaufen konnte. Irgendwann war das Ding verstorben, und dann hatten wir aber noch irgendwo so ein zweites kaputtes hergekriegt, und dann hat sie halt so noch in so einer Aus-zwei-mach-einen-Aktion jemand von euch schon mal so ein Display bei so einem MacBook ausgetauscht?
Ja, damals noch Titan, oder wie die hießen. So diese ersten G4 Powerbox. Oh mein Gott, ich glaube, ich mache das nie noch wieder.
Also wir haben jedenfalls bei diesem MacBook Pro Unibody Aluminium mit hier so mit Scheibe das Ding ausgetauscht, und das ist schon hardcore. Da muss man so mit Saugnäpfen und Heißluftpistole außen den Kleber weichen.
Da muss man schon schmerzfrei sein, ja.
Aber das darf halt nicht zu heiß werden. Also eigentlich muss man das fast zu zweit machen, weil wenn man es zu heiß wird, dann wiederum verfärbt sich das Display dauerhaft. Wenn du es nicht heiß genug machst, bricht dir das Glas so. Und gleichzeitig musst du mit Saugnäpfen, aber die Saugnäpfe darfst du halt nicht voll durchspannen, weil dann bricht dir auch das Glas erwärms. Tatsächlich geschafft, dann zu zweit dort auch noch.
Wozu muss man es heiß machen, damit der Kleber so ein bisschen...
Das Display ist hier außen, das schwarze, das ist halt einfach verklebt. Das ist halt einfach aufgeklebt, hier die Scheibe.
Mit dem Föhn irgendwie ordentlich warm machen?
Ja, Föhn reicht nicht. Du musst ungefähr das Ding auf 100 Grad... Nur vier? Das muss richtig warm werden, aber eben nicht zu warm. Sonst, wie gesagt, ist das Display im Arsch. Und dann musst du halt vorsichtig mit dem Saugnapf so, während du das erhitzt so langsam, löst sich dann der Kleber. Und dann musst du so mit Spachtel, aber auch nicht... Also, weil die Scheibe ist halt sau dünn. Und das war das Hardcore-mäßigste.
Und warum habt ihr nicht einfach den gesamten Deckel getauscht?
Das geht nicht.
Das ging aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Weil, ehrlich gesagt, die im Apple-Shop, die werden doch da nicht diese Scheibe rausholen.
Die schmeißen das weg und machen die da... Die machen da wahrscheinlich mit neuem Deckel. Die tauschen das ganze Teil aus. Das glaube ich auch. Und zwar, das Problem war, dass hier sitzen irgendwelche Übertrager oder Verstärker noch mit drin. Das Problem war schlichtweg. Dass... Wir hatten zwei, aber bei dem einen funktionierenden Display war die Scheibe kaputt. Bei dem anderen war das Display kaputt, aber die Scheibe heile. Ich lasse jetzt meine Tochter mal die ganzen Mac-Schrauben rein. Die habe ich zu Weihnachten auch so ein komplettes Mac-Schraubkit mit einem Spezialwerkzeug geschenkt. Wenn da ein neues Betriebssystem oder ein Update zu installieren ist, oder auch für Tante, dann macht sie jetzt die Mac-System-Administration und die Mac-Hardware-Schraube rein.
Und wie zufrieden bist du so mit Apple derzeit?
Also, wo soll ich anfangen? Also erstens hier, gut, dieses Gerät hier, dieses Highend rechts unten Gerät ist eigentlich ganz nett, aber sie haben irgendwie die LED abgeschafft, hier so das, also Betriebszustand, hier ist nichts, keine Betriebszustand.
Das Problem ist, du weißt nicht, ob der Rechner an ist, weil ist ja eine SSD drin und du hast keine Status-LED. Und wenn der Bildschirm aus ist?
Ja, also es fehlt die Status-LED, es fehlt die Batterieanzeige, also Lade-Dingens.
Die gibt es auch nicht mehr hier, dass man hier sagen kann?
Nee, also voll hier gespart, denn gut, die Einschalt-Taste, dass sie jetzt nicht im Alu haben, sondern hier mit auf der Tastatur.
Find ich eigentlich eher schicker.
Geschenkt, ja, dann einfach, also ihr hättet ruhig ein paar mehr Ports noch spendieren können. Ja gut, zweimal, also es fehlen mir USB-Ports, also ich hätte gerne, also ich hab hier nur zwei USB-Ports, das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Links und rechts, ne?
Aber ok, bis auf hier, wie gesagt, dass sie halt hier so geizig waren mit LED und Anzeigen und so.
Die ist so, deswegen, weil iOS ist doch jetzt always on. Dein Rechner ist einfach immer an, da braucht man keine Lampe mehr. Der ist an, immer.
Er braucht beim Aufklappen relativ lange, bis die WLAN-Verbindung wieder steht. Ist das ein Software-Problem? Wie auch immer.
Yosemite und Wifi und Bluetooth. Und gerade diese Kombination, das haben sie immer noch nicht im Griff.
Das fand ich auf jeden Fall generell auch so ein Nachteil hier. Also von dem Gerät, das man Yosemite braucht, dass es funktioniert, das ist auch so ein Nachteil. Ja, ansonsten Audio. Ich finde, also der Audio-Kopfhörerausgang ist nicht ganz so geil wie der von meinem 17 Zoller. Also ist okay. Lautstärke ein bisschen. Also ist ein bisschen vielleicht etwas andere im Bendans. Also er ist nicht, also auf meinem 17 Zoller, da habe ich halt diese Bayer Dynamik DT 990 und 880 dran und wenn ich die direkt dran hänge, super geiler Sound. Hier auch ziemlich geil, aber eben ticken, haben sie nachgelassen. Minimal, aber ich kann es halt schon hören, das ist eine leicht andere Impendanz. Wie auch immer. Und die Batterie wird zu schnell leer. In meinem 17 Zoller hatte ich die 13.500 mAh und der Verbrauch war ungefähr vergleichbar. Sprich, die Batterie von meinem 17 Zoller hält halt doppelt so lange wie von dem Gerät. Wie lange? Wenn die voll ist, also 4,5 Stunden Action und 8 Stunden so umstehen lassen.
Meins hält ja schon 7 Stunden und das ist jetzt wie alt? 4 Jahre alt? Dann müsste doch dein Retina-Hasswell super mit riesen Batterien, weil gar nichts mehr zu öffnen irgendwie oder auszutauschen, müsste doch da viel länger halten. War nicht relativ gut in der Zeit?
Also das hält 4 Stunden, wenn man nichts macht. Und 2 Stunden, ja.
Da hast du dir aber irgendeinen Schädling eingefangen.
Nee, nee, nee. Ich guck mal bei Apfel.
Oder du benutzt Xcode.
Oder hast du irgendeinen... Der Flash im Hintergrund.
Das ist es.
Ich hab jetzt hier... Also ja, nee, es ist einfach verglichen mit meinem 17 Zoller. Hältet einfach nicht so lange hier, das Ding. Das ist jetzt nur ganz kurz hier zu dem...
8 Stunden, sagen sie bei Abfehl. 8 Stunden Wireless oder 8 Stunden iTunes mit Playback?
Ja, nee, vergiss es.
95 Watt, das ist schon ganz schön fett.
Ich mein, gut, ich hab natürlich auch...
Watt ist nicht entscheidend, Ampere-Stunden ist entscheidend.
Ja, genau.
Du kannst ja umrechnen.
Eigentlich Wattstunden.
Ich hab natürlich auch den 2,8 Gigahertz-Prozessor drin und die 16 Gigabyte...
Du hast den großen Prozessor. Das darf man sowieso nie machen.
Hab ich auch gemacht, mach ich immer.
Gut, und...
Ja, egal, wurscht. Aber das ist... Ich hab einen auf hohem Niveau, auf jeden Fall. Ja, aber trotzdem ist es ärgert, wenn man plötzlich irgendwie nicht sehen kann, ist das Ding nicht an oder nicht. Ich war enttäuscht. Ich war enttäuscht, dass... Auch noch die letzte LED hier. Und vor allem, wenn es nicht angeht. Das ist dann halt... Hier hat sie dann wenigstens noch mit Blinkcodes.
Die Vorgabe ist, das geht jetzt immer an.
Der Unterschied ist echt deutlich. Wenn man dann so einen Mac mit einer Festplatte hat, da drückst du drauf und es macht Klack. Weil sich der Kopf von dieser Festplatte bewegt und dann hört man die Festplatte hochlaufen.
Und da hört man die Lüfter.
Da passiert halt nichts. Nee, Lüfter hörst du auch nicht.
Das ist bestimmt...
Müssen wir das mal simulieren, so wie Elektroautofiereinrichtungen geräuft machen.
Ja, das ist bestimmt hier... Also ich warte darauf, dass der ist lebensgefährlich ohne die LED. Weil ich stelle dir vor, das Ding läuft noch irgendwie. Ich sehe es aber nicht. Packt es in die Tasche. Das überhitzt. Und dann brennt mir die Bude ab. Und dann ersticken Leute an Rauchgas. Ich finde, der Apple gehört verklagt.
Bitte, wenn du es zumachst, das ist doch aus.
Woher willst du das wissen? Also ich habe... Das ist irgendwie Software-System-Management-Controller.
Die LED würde ja auch nur von Software angesteuert.
Vor allem wäre die LED trotzdem leuchtend.
Genau, dann könnte ich aber wenigstens sehen... Also da sehe ich halt dann an der... Also erstens an der pulsierenden LED, ob der System-Management-Controller in Ordnung ist und den in den Schlafzustand versetzt hat. Während wenn dann plötzlich die LED entweder leuchtet oder nicht leuchtet oder so, wüsste ich halt, irgendwas stimmt da nicht. Wie gesagt, jedenfalls wegen der fehlenden LED brennt noch irgendwann mal eine Bude ab, weil jemand das eingeschaltete Gerät... Genau, Class Action Suit.
Aber es war doch so, dass das Ding sowieso auch bei zugeschaltet, also zugeklappten Deckel, sowieso auch selber aufwacht und schon im Hintergrund Sachen macht. Also der geht doch sowieso auch von alleine an. Haben die doch jetzt alles so geregelt.
Wenn du ihn am Strom hast.
Nur dann?
Ah ja, eine Sache noch, von wegen Softwarequalität. Mir ist bei dem 17 Zoller, ist mir die Batterie so gestorben, dass sie sich irgendwie komplett verabschiedet hat. Original Apple Batterie. Was dazu führte, dass aber erstens, wurde sie angezeigt als 99% voll. Zweitens, hat irgendein Prozess, der sie ausgelesen hat, war im Spinlock, sodass ich, sodass die CPU mit, also ein Kern mit 100% CPU-Last lief, weil die Batterie kaputt war. Und wenn ich den Prozess gekillt habe, war ich, bzw. egal ob ich ihn gekillt habe oder nicht, sondern weil der irgendwo hing, war ich nicht mehr in der Lage, die Display-Helligkeit zu regulieren. So viel zur, ich sag mal, internen Software-Qualität. Wenn die Batterie nicht erreichbar ist, dann zieht da 100% CPU und du kannst die Display-Helligkeit nicht mehr regulieren. Ich meine, was ist denn das für eine Gülle?
Das war jetzt beim 17-Zoll.
Na gut, da hat sich das halt einfach mal bemerkbar gemacht. Aber das ist halt nicht Qualitätssoftware. Da sieht man halt, dass auf der Ebene irgendwie System-Management-Controller das Ding so, dann tauscht du die Batterie aus. Und dann auch irgendwie Hell-Breaks los nach dem Batterieaustausch. Erstens weigert er sich, die Batterie zu laden, bevor du nicht irgendwie einen System-Management-Controller und Parameter-Ram-Reset durchgeführt hast, weil er sich irgendwas da drin merkt, aber nicht mitkriegt, dass da eine neue Batterie ist. Dann lädt er erstmal die Batterie nicht.
Die Batterie ist wahrscheinlich ein eigenständiges Wesen mit einer eigenen ID und das System-Management-Controller hat wahrscheinlich die ID von der alten Batterie gespeichert, spricht die an und dann ist keine da.
Ja, aber nach dem Wechsel hätte er wenigstens erkennen können, ah, neue Batterie, ok, da muss ich mich irgendwie... Aber nüscht, so wechselst du die Batterie aus und geht erstmal nicht.
Das ist die ähnliche Geschichte wie bei meinem Display, wo sie mal die Scheibe getauscht haben, weil es kaputt war. Und danach konnte ich irgendwie die Helligkeit von dem Display nicht mehr einstellen, weil jetzt das Display und die Restelektronik von dem Display, da stimmten die I.D.s nicht mehr überein. Und da musste ich so ein komisches Tool versorgen und das wieder in Sync bringen und dann ging auch wieder alles.
Genau, also jedenfalls nach Batteriewechsel unbedingt mindestens wohl Parameter-Ramm resetten, aber unter Umständen auch System-Management-Controller resetten. Da denkst du natürlich erst mal, du tauschst die Batterie, dass deine neue Batterie im Arsch ist, weil irgendwie nichts geht.
Aber bei dem 17 Zöller konnte man den noch ganz normal rausnehmen unten, oder? Ach so, auch schon.
Ist auch schon.
Das heißt eigentlich, die im Apple laden, wenn die dir die Batterie tauschen, dann machen die das alles?
Vermutlich, ja. Aber ja, nichtsdestotrotz ist das halt keine, finde ich, ist das nicht Qualitätssoftware. Das ist nach einem Batterietausch, der die Batterie nicht lädt. Das ist nicht, das ist, also, ja, wer schreibt sowas?
So.
Ich merke, ich komme langsam in Fahrt.
Ich frage mich, wie dein Review von Yosemite aussieht.
Nee, lass uns, don't let us get into that. So, dann, iPad. iPad und in der iTunes kommt, bzw. eigentlich ist es, ich glaube, es ist auch, also, iOS 8. Hat das Problem, dass wenn du Bücher synchronisierst, dass er und du mehr als, sagen wir mal, 300, 400 Bücher hast, meist sogar, also er schafft nur 200 Bücher in einem zu synchronisieren und dann stürzen auf dem Gerät irgendwelche Prozesse ab und, ja. Und das heißt, wenn du jetzt 2000 Bücher hast, dann musst du irgendwie 10- bis 15-mal hintereinander auf synchronisieren klicken. Dann dauert es irgendwie Minuten, bis er dann wirklich anfängt zu synchronisieren. Dann macht er halt 150-200 Bücher weiter, so bleibt wieder hängen. Das heißt, es ist einfach komplett ungeeignet für größere Mengen an Büchern. Und dieses Problem ist, würde man sagen, seit fast einem Jahr besteht das. Eigentlich von Anfang an war das mit iOS 8 da und teilweise auch in iOS 7. Also in anderen Worten, Bücher synchronisieren ist seit ewigen Zeiten broken. Aber wer hat auch schon mehr als 200 Bücher, die ja synchronisieren?
Du musst an eine amerikanische Bücherschrankgröße denken.
Ja, so und ja, also das so dann aus Entwicklersicht bei iOS 8 haben sie haufenweise Änderungen an der API gemacht, die sie aber nicht wirklich zusammenhängend jetzt dokumentiert hatten. Was dazu? Also so ganz einmal haben sie ja das Permissionsystem verfeinert, auf was man... Ja, es gibt jetzt zum Beispiel, glaube ich, auch getrennte irgendwie Kamera-Permissions und Album-Permissions und so, die nicht automatisch... Also man muss jedenfalls jetzt mehr Permissions einholen. Das ist aber, wie gesagt, nur eine Sache. Jedenfalls führt das halt dazu, dass ja, teilweise eben Apps plötzlich die Permissions... Also sie haben jedenfalls da Änderungen gemacht, die dazu führten, dass deine App nicht mehr kompatibel ist. Dann haben sie angefangen, dann haben sie halt teilweise Delegate-Schnittstellen geändert, beziehungsweise rufen jetzt bestimmte Dinge von anderen Prozessen auf, was auch wiederum ungefähr jetzt bei verschiedenen Pickern, die da waren, gefühlt die Hälfte der Apps nicht mehr im Store nicht mehr richtig funktionierte an bestimmten Stellen. Wenn du irgendwelche Adress-Picker oder andere Sachen hattest. Dann mit dem ganzen, dieser ganze Auto-Layout-Kram, der ist zwar besser geworden von iOS 7 zu iOS 8, führt aber auch dazu, dass es...
Funktioniert das erstmal ordentlich.
Ja, aber es führt dann trotzdem wieder zu Kompatibilitätsproblemen. Also Sachen, die du unter iOS 7 zum Funktionieren gebracht hattest, sahen plötzlich unter iOS 8 wieder anders aus, weil sie Bugs gefixt hatten teilweise. Dann soll noch...
Ja, also wir hatten diese ganzen Probleme nicht, aber...
Also mit Hoccer benutzen wir fast einmal komplett quer durch, fast alles an APIs, 70-80% der vorhandenen APIs, weil wir greifen auf Bilder, auf Kamera, auf Netzwerk, auf was auch immer, Mikrofon, Musik. Also es gibt wenig, was wir nicht benutzen. Das heißt, wir haben ungefähr, die App hat keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich 100 Screens oder so insgesamt, also sag mal vielleicht 20, 30 Layouts oder so. Jedenfalls selten gut von 6 auf 7 war halt auch, aber das war halt mit Ansagen. Da war halt klar, okay, da ist halt ein Kompliment.
Ja, aber von 6 auf 7 war ja die echte Katastrophe. Also das war ja, das war ja...
Ja, allerdings haben sie das...
Das war ja Krieg, also...
Ja, allerdings haben sie das wenigstens so gemacht, mit Kriegserklärung halt. Und da wusste man halt, okay, im Prinzip muss ich einen großen Teil neu schreiben. Das war halt klar, das Fiese von 7 auf 8 war, dass sie da Gerillakrieg...
Das einzige Problem, was wir halt hatten, war dieses Location-Ding, was ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, weil unter iOS 7 hast du halt eine Location-Permission. Und die hast du halt immer, ob du sie im Hintergrund verwendest oder nicht. Und unter iOS 8 hast du halt entweder eine Location-Permission für immer oder eine Location-Permission nur, wenn die App läuft. Und das eigentlich merkwürdig ist aber, dass du die Permission tatsächlich proaktiv holen musst. Sonst versuchst du eine Location zu bekommen und es passiert nichts.
Ja, das hatten wir auch, aber das tritt eben nicht nur bei Location auf, sondern auch noch bei anderen Teilen der Toolbox. Nur, wie gesagt, dass es jetzt nicht ein Dokument gab, wo drin stand. Wo wir es dann dokumentiert gefunden haben, nicht immer bei Apple. Und wir wissen halt, dass viele Leute dieselben Probleme hatten. Und insofern habe ich das Gefühl, wenn man das Telefon am Logger hängen hat, also früher war das nur unter Android so, dass dir alle möglichen Systemprozesse, wo irgendjemand mal Testausgaben vergessen hatte, dir das Log zumüllen mit irgendwelchen schwachsinnigen Meldungen. Inzwischen hat Apple da komplett aufgeholt. Also auch wenn du irgendwie ein nagelneues Telefon einfach anschließt und dir das Log anguckst, dann wird das Log voll gekotzt mit irgendwelchen komplett sinnlosen Log- und Fehlermeldungen, wo du denkst, ey, was ist denn das? Und da sieht man halt, okay, da herrscht halt keine Disziplin in der Entwicklungsabteilung. Da kann halt jeder seine Testausgaben straflos drinlassen, die dann das Log zumüllen und ja, nichts passiert. Seit Jobs nicht mehr da ist, habe ich das Gefühl, so macht da jeder, was er will. Da bauen sie.
Du meinst, Steve hat sich die Logs angeguckt?
Pff, ne, zumindest. Ich meine, in großen Konzernen ist das so, da hast du halt deinen eigenen Geheimdienst als Vorstand, weil die Wahrheit sagt dir sowieso keiner. Das heißt, du musst sowieso, hast speziell Leute, die halt in der Firma rumrennen und dir die Wahrheit sagen. So ist das organisiert. Und ich wette, Jobs hat das genauso gemacht. Also es ist halt heute Standard in Großunternehmen, das so halt als Vorstand, deine eigene Intelligenz, die sagt, deine Untergebenen belügen dich alle.
Da spricht jemand aus Erfahrung, oder?
Ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen.
Und ich meine, dann bauen sie hier jetzt so ein Tello. Ich meine, dass sie einen Bildschirm größer gemacht haben. Okay, ich finde es auch gut. Leute werden älter, demografischer Wandel und so. Die können alle nicht mehr so gut sehen. Und ich finde das auch ganz okay. Aber dann, ey, ich meine...
Die Kamera.
Ja, wie kann man irgendwie eine Kamera bauen, die hinten aus dem Gehäuse rausguckt? Das heißt, man kann das Ding nirgendwo ablegen. Das ist ein Telefon, das kann man ohne Hülle nicht betreiben. Bzw. ohne Hülle kannst du es nirgendwo ablegen, sonst war ja die Linse verkratzt.
Dafür ist das ja aus Saphir, damit es nicht zerkratzt.
Hatten wir vorhin auch das Thema. Ich kann dir meine verkratzten anderen Saphir-Linsen zeigen.
Das ist das Problem, weil es Saphir ankratzen kann.
Wenn du es auf deinen Saphirtisch legst, zum Beispiel ein zerkratztes.
Es war doch in einem Film, wo die Frau reinkommt und ihr Goldschmuck verkaufen will. Sie sagt, sie kratzt über seinen Glastisch und kratzt auch Glas auf. Der Juwelier juvuliert ganz locker, ja, Glas kratzt auch Glas auf. Sie hat sie dann als Fälschung enttarnt und sie wieder rausgeschickt. Irgendwann gibt es im Film eine sehr witzige Szene.
Dann das Gehäuse hier so rundlich. Eigentlich sieht es aus wie aus Blech gestanzt. Also sieht aus wie so ein Blech-Stanz-Gehäuse. Ja, nee, noch nicht mal. Sondern sieht aus wie irgendwie Blech mit Ofenbronze.
Ja, und diese komischen Streifen dafür lackiert.
Ja, und die Streifen hier, also, ja, von der...
Pavel, warum holst du so einen Scheiß auf? 5S, das ist das Telefon, was man will, ne, Timme?
Ja, ich habe ja auch gleich einen 5S.
Es ist einfach kein besseres Design als das 5S. Es ist einfach das Telefon.
Ich habe halt noch einen 5er und einen 4er nur zu beruhen. Also ich, bloß, ich kann halt, da wir halt Software entwickeln...
Eigentlich brauchst du ja auch einen 6 Plus.
Muss ich das, ja, eigentlich schon, aber...
Das ist auch so das richtig, so das gerundische Telefon dann.
Ja, ja, das ist genau.
Beim 6 Plus guckt die Kamera aber auch noch aus. Na ja, ist ja genauso flach.
Und von vorne sieht es halt aus wie so ein Samsung Galaxy.
Ja, weil es in weiß ist.
Weil die sind ja alle immer in weiß.
Hätte ich jetzt auch vorhin die ganze Zeit gedacht.
Also in weiß, wenn er nicht... Also ja, sieht halt aus wie so ein Samsung...
Kaufst du das auch in weiß?
Ja, ich brauchte das halt sofort.
Das ist ein Fickler, der braucht das in weiß.
Nee, ist mir... Weil Farbe war mir scheißegal. Ich hab auch...
War mir scheißegal. Guck mal, wie das aussieht in weiß. Ich mein, wer macht denn das in weiß? Farbe war mir scheißegal.
Ja, nee, ich mein, wenn man... Ja, nee. Ich seh schon Farbe. Wenn man's in weiß anbietet, so... Also wenn man...
Da muss doch der Bildschirm weiß sein.
Nee.
Also man darf's einfach nicht in scheiße aussehend bauen überhaupt. Und in Handel.
Es sieht ja jetzt nicht wirklich anders aus, als das iPhone 5 vorher auch aussah in weiß.
Doch.
Nee, anders nicht genau. Genauso. Scheiße. Ich find, weiß geht gar nicht.
Nee, aber das hatte wenigstens einen vernünftigen Rand. Aber wie auch immer dann...
Das ist immer lieber relevante Sachen unterhalten.
Dann ist es instabil. Dann ist es, du musst es halt regelmäßig, also wir sind dahingekommen, musst es halt regelmäßig rebooten. So. Sonst irgendwann fangen halt Dinge an langsam zu werden. Oder fangen halt Dinge an nicht mehr richtig zu funktionieren. So. Also ohne, ich sag mal...
Das ist jetzt die letzte?
Ja, das ist die letzte Toffifee.
Krass, da hab ich alle geschafft. Eine Fresse.
Also ich muss das Gerät so im Schnitt einmal in der Woche rebooten, weil irgendwas nicht mehr richtig tut. Und es ist kein Hardware-Problem, sondern das ist...
Hatte ich noch nie bei meinem Telefon, glaube ich. Also bei dem Modell.
Ja, du hast aber auch kein iPhone 6.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, also das war wirklich in der Kombination auch mit iOS 8. So, und Ähnliches auch mit den iPads. Die sind halt auch buggy. Ich meine, man kann's benutzen, alles, aber es ist halt... Es ist halt, ja...
Gut, ich hab nicht eins von den allernäuesten iPads. Obwohl, so mit Buggy-Netz hab ich jetzt kein Problem.
Aber du hast ja noch kein Android, also so schlimm kann's ja dann nicht sein.
Also der Browser stürzt, also Safari stürzt, ständig ab auf manchen Webseiten. Und dann kommt er ständig immer wieder mit der Meldung hoch. So hat sich halt neu gestartet, weil ein Problem aufgetreten ist. Ich mein, und Apple ist halt einfach, die sind potgeizig, was RAM und irgendwie Flash angeht. Das finde ich, ich mein, wenn die wenigstens einem hier so viel Schipse aus der Tasche ziehen, würde ich wenigstens erwarten, dass sie da wenigstens ordentlich RAM und Flash reintun. Und da muss aber dann auch, da zocken sie sich dann ab. Deswegen kaufe ich aus Protest mittlerweile das kleinste. Modell.
Ja, mehr RAM kostet aber auch mehr Strom und mehr Flash nicht. Also dass sie überhaupt so niedrig einsteigen.
Und das Flash ist grottenlangsam. Ich habe das jetzt mal neulich gebenchmarkt.
Ja, das ist keine SSD, das ist irgendwie klar, oder?
Es ist eine SSD.
Ja, aber es ist nicht mit dem Controller von dem Flash. Also das macht ja die SSD aus, oder das, was du jetzt als SSD bezeichnest. Der Controller.
Ja, das, was ich als SSD bezeichne, ist größer als dieses Telefon. Also insofern.
So.
Pavel ist nicht sehr bekannt für seinen Benchmark.
3 Megabyte pro Sekunde. Maximal Read oder Write-Durchsatz. 3 Megabyte pro Sekunde. Das heißt, das Problem ist, das Netzwerk, die Netzwerkschnittstelle ist deutlich schneller.
Wie schnell ist denn Samsung?
Die Mikro-Dingens, die man jetzt auch hier in den ganzen Kameras und so... Genau, diese Mikro-SD gehen bis 30 Megabyte pro Sekunde.
Du bist ja sicher drei Megabyte pro Sekunde.
Hier, danke. Es ist so richtig...
Du könntest ja überhaupt HD Movies abspülen.
RAM, Netzwerkschnittstelle, also das Problem ist...
Was hat HD Movie so viele Bitrate? Wir haben so sechs Megabit oder so, ne?
Das ist schon viel, glaub ich, oder?
Das geht noch. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Und das Problem ist, was ich halt neulich hatte, so was ich auch nicht... Ich hab halt von draußen halt über die Netzwerkschnittstelle Daten in das Gerät hochgeladen, die ich halt wegschreiben wollte. Und da war eben das Problem, dass die Daten halt schneller eintrafen, als er sie wegschreiben konnte. Aber ich konnte sie aus dem User-Space zwar schnell genug wegschreiben, aber irgendwelche Kernel-Buffer sind halt deswegen so angewachsen, ohne dass ich das aber kontrollieren konnte, dass irgendwann er, obwohl eigentlich ich gar nicht viel Speicher gebraucht habe, das Gerät die App wegen einer Low-Memory-Warning gekillt hat, nur weil irgendwelcher unsichtbarer Kernel-Speicher-Buffer sich irgendwie 500 Megabyte oder so dort an irgendwelchen Buffern irgendwo angesammelt haben, nur weil er nicht schnell genug wegschreiben konnte. Und mit so einem Scheiß hast du dann zu kämpfen und willst jetzt eigentlich nur Daten über die Netzwerkschnittstelle entgegennehmen und wegschreiben. Und dann, puh.
Also ich sehe schon, du bist unzufrieden.
Ich, ja.
Ich wollte nochmal auf die etwas fortgeschrittene Zeit hinweisen und vielleicht nochmal einen kleinen Themenschwung vornehmen. Abgesehen davon, dass ich noch einen kleinen Produktbericht habe, aber nur einen kleinen, hat glaube ich Roddy noch ein bisschen was aus der Welt, der Poamirsprachen zu berichten.
Richtig? Ja, naja, Swift 1.2 ist erschienen. Gibt es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so viel zu sagen. Sie haben mal wieder ein paar Sachen weggemacht, die nervig sind. Unter anderem das Pyramid of Doom Problem. Ja, Pyramid of Doom ist eigentlich ein Ausdruck, der aus der JavaScript-Welt kommt.
Heißt das nicht Pyramid?
Ja, habe ich das falsch ausgesprochen?
Nein, du hast es richtig ausgesprochen. Dennis denkt wahrscheinlich an Dynamite.
Verstehe.
Also, das Ding ist... Es gibt ja in Swift diese Optionals, also es gibt Variablen, die können entweder in Wert enthalten oder nil sein. Und es gibt so ein Konstrukt, wo man sagt, if var, dieses da ist, gleich das andere, bekommt man, wenn da tatsächlich nicht nil drin ist, bekommt man erstens die Variable als nicht Optional und zweitens mal geht er dann in das if-Konstrukt rein. Was? Also, nochmal, es gibt Variablen, die enthalten entweder direkt den Typ, also das Objekt einer Klasse.
Du kannst sagen, ob da eine Null drin ist oder ob da einfach nichts drin ist. Du kannst auf nichts checken, das ist da jetzt nochmal ein Unterschied.
Okay, wenn du in einer normalen, sagen wir, du hast zehn und du hast nil.
Okay, eine Variable kann nil sein, das ist das, was du sagen möchtest. Das war vorher nicht so.
Es gibt zwei Typen von Variablen, die einen können nil sein, die anderen können nicht nil sein. Wenn du bei C zum Beispiel einen Pointer hast, gut, bei C gibt es die Möglichkeit, der Pointer zeigt auf was sinnvoll ist, der Pointer zeigt auf nichts Sinnvolles und der Pointer ist nul. Das sind die drei Möglichkeiten, die du bei C hast. Die zweite Möglichkeit führt in der Regel zum Crash. So, die dritte Möglichkeit gerne zum Crash, aber nicht unbedingt. Wenn du jetzt bei Objective-C, kann jetzt ein Pointer zum Beispiel nil, also nul sein, ohne dass was Schlimmes passiert, weil du kannst eine Methode auf einem Nil-Pointer aufrufen. Unter Objective-C ist eine...
Ist das ja bedefiniert.
Ja, das ist so eine Eigenart von Objective-C, die einem aber viel Ärger erspart. So, jetzt gibt es unter Swift keine Pointer mehr, bei Design, weil Pointer sind halt irgendwie eine Gefahrenquelle. Letztes Jahr 1000 und Gefahrenquelle und haste nicht gesehen. So, und jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass du sagst, meine Variable hat immer einen Wert, oder aber meine Variable hat entweder einen Wert oder ist nil. So, der erste Fall, also der zweite Fall heißt optional. Der erste Fall, der hat keinen besonderen Namen. So, und wenn du jetzt eine Methode aufrufen willst, wo du ein non-optional rein gibst.
Also einer, der nil sein kann.
Nein, einer, der nicht nil sein kann. Du hast aber einen optional. Also, du hast als Eingabeparameter der Methode einen Wert, der muss immer da sein. Und du hast aber einen optional. Dann musst du jetzt aus dem optional etwas machen, was nicht nil sein kann, also ein non-optional. Und dafür gibt es einen Konstrukt, nämlich eine spezielle Art der if-Abfrage, wo du innerhalb des ifs einer neuen Variable den Wert zuweist, wenn er nicht nil ist.
Und dann gehst du in den Zweig von dem if.
Also eine konditionale Zuweisung.
Eine konditionale Zuweisung, genau.
Conditional Assignment auch.
So, und wenn du jetzt aber mehrere Variablen hast, die du alle deoptionalisieren willst, nenne ich das jetzt mal, dann hast du ein if-dings, dann if-dings, dann if-dings, dann if-dings, dann if-dings und dann bekommst du diese Pyramid of Doom. Also es sieht halt so aus wie so eine Pyramide, weil mit jedem if deine Einrückung größer wird, als hättest du eine riesige Pyramide aus Zeug aufgebaut.
Ja, okay, und was ist jetzt das Problem?
Ja, und was ist die Lösung von dem Problem?
Die Lösung des Problems ist, dass du jetzt in einem if mehrere Zuweisungen machen kannst und das if nur dann ausgeführt wird, wenn wirklich alle Zuweisungen klappen.
Sie haben einfach sozusagen bei dem Optional-Checking das End eingebaut.
Na, ich würde sagen, es ist mehr als syntaktischer Zucker, weil das andere war...
Da ist jetzt nichts Neues dazugekommen.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass diese Sprache doch ganz schön komplex ist.
Was eigentlich neu dazugekommen ist, ist, dass es einen Set-Typ gibt. Also das, was vorher ein Set war, also halt...
Eine Menge.
Eine Menge, ja.
Wo jedes Objekt genau einmal drin sein kann.
Genau.
Das gab es vorher nicht.
Oder nicht.
Und vorher gab es nur Array und Dictionary und jetzt gibt es halt Array, Dictionary und Set. Das war so eine Auslassung, wo man sich gefragt hat, hä, wieso, jetzt haben sie es reingemacht, alles super.
Alles für Sachen, die Smalltalk schon 1970 hatte.
Manche Sachen davon hatte Smalltalk 1970.
Gut, es gibt auch Gründe, warum keiner mehr Smalltalk benutzt.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt nicht Smalltalk preisen.
Ich wollte nur sagen, das ist auch irgendwie so. Nee, aber du hattest mich ja eigentlich angesprochen, dass diese, wie hieß er, Accidental Tech Podcasts da die neueste Sendung, dass die ja so interessant wäre, fand ich jetzt nicht. Ich fand das irgendwie anstrengend, eineinhalb Stunden.
Was, du hast dir die ganze Sendung angehört? Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, worum es ging.
Na, es ging um Swift. Also das Schlimme war, die drei Typen, die reden halt alle drei davon, dass sie keine Ahnung haben, wie es jetzt um Swift bestellt ist, weil sie Swift nicht machen würden, weil sich Swift ja ständig ändern würde. Also auf gut Deutsch drei Nacktschnecken reden vom Fliegen, weil sie alle drei keine Ahnung haben.
Gut, das können wir aber auch.
Ja, das können wir auch, aber wir sagen es meistens dazu, während die halt so rumgeeiert haben und einfach gesagt haben, irgendwie die halbe Sprache würde sich ständig ändern. Was jetzt nicht stimmt, es gibt halt immer wieder Kleinigkeiten, ja klar, dann kommt Swift 1, 2 raus und dann kompiliert der Code nicht mehr. Dann ändert man ein paar Sachen und innerhalb von einer Viertelstunde, halben Stunde hat man seinen Code wieder da, wo er vorher war.
Ja, mein Objective-C hat sich ja auch so ohne Ende geändert, irgendwie in den letzten…
Na ja, aber es war schon graduell.
Du meinst ja mit Objective-C 2.0 und so, mit den ganzen Sachen?
Ja, mit ARK und…
Ja, okay, ARK und dieser kurze Ausflug in die Garbage Collection.
Ja, die Flucht von der Garbage Collection.
Also, ich meine, das Meister von… Das bin ich zum Glück verschont von geblieben, weil ich gesagt habe, er ist relativ spät vor… Ich weiß nicht, vor drei Jahren damit angefangen hat oder… Und insofern… Ich weiß nicht, ich hab halt dieses Swift, ich hab mir halt die Präsentation angeguckt, ich hab mir halt ein bisschen so da reingelesen und das ist… also ich seh jetzt, ich mein, es ist halt eine vereinfachte Syntax im Wesentlichen plus ein paar schicke Tools, von denen ich aber eigentlich das Gefühl hab, dass ich relativ sicher weiß, dass sie komplett nutzlos sind für die Anwendungsfälle.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wovon du redest.
Naja, die Möglichkeit, hier Sachen aufzunehmen und die Verknüpfung mit Grafik und den…
Auch diese Sandbox, oder wie die da heißt?
Playground. Playground.
Ja gut, das ist halt so ein Gimmick, was du da…
Playground ist ein Gimmick, aber das macht die Sprache ja an sich nicht schlecht. Also ich find, die Sprache ist ein echter Quantensprung zur Objective-C. Und ich hab auch das Gefühl, es geht eher so in die funktionale Richtung. Also gerade mit dem Ding, dass halt Dictionary, Array und Set sind halt nicht mehr, haben keine Objektsymmantik mehr, sondern eine Value-Symmantik. Das heißt, also nehmen wir an, du hast einen Array mit drei Objekten, eins, zwei, drei, vier, weißt du der Variable A zu, dann weißt du der Variable B, die Variable A zu. Das heißt, B hat auch einen Array mit den Werten eins, zwei, drei, vier, eins, zwei, drei. So, jetzt hängst du an die Variable B, an das Array noch einen Wert ran. Was passiert? Bei Objective-C ist es so, dass A sich mit ändert, weil es Objektsymmantik ist. Aber bei Swift bleibt A so, wie es ist und nur B bekommt das weitere Objekt.
Ja, wenn du es über die Zuweisung machst, wobei du natürlich genau aus dem Grund, damit es halt nicht passiert, du ja alle möglichen Init und sonst wie konstruier mir das Array aus einem anderen Array-Methoden hast, die vermutlich genau bei Swift auch drunterliegen die das irgendwie wahrscheinlich sogar lazy machen und so.
Die machen das lazy, ja.
Copy and write und so, ja?
Ja, sie machen es lazy.
Und insofern ist das wahrscheinlich, haben sie einfach wahrscheinlich das, was man sowieso machen soll jetzt mit Indie-Syntax reingepackt.
Ja, bei Objective-C musst du halt, du musst halt ein Immutable-Array machen, dann kannst du das Immutable-Array kopieren oder du hast ein Mutable, dann musst du das Mutable kopieren, dann musst du das Mutable hinzufügen, das kann man alles machen, aber am Ende des Tages ist es halt gefährlicher zu machen. Also du merkst, wirklich bei Swift haben sie wirklich ganz krass versucht, alles rauszubauen, was die Sprache gefährlich macht. Und wenn man also dann auch so mit Generics und so weiter arbeitet, dann hat man so das, irgendwann kommt so der Punkt und man denkt sich so, wie konnte ich vorher damit arbeiten, dass ein Array keine Typisierung hat? Dass man da irgendwelche Objekte reinschmeißen muss und dass ich am Anfang jeder Methode anfange, meine Parameter Asserts zu machen, ob ich Objekte bekomme, ob ich die richtigen Objekte bekomme und so weiter. Also das ist so.
Ja, es war auch schon ein bisschen ein Rückschritt, also ich hab halt vorher C++, so das was ich über Jahrzehnte gefühlt gemacht habe und gut, man kann jetzt auch Objective C++ natürlich programmieren.
Jaja, ich weiß, das geht, aber da muss man wirklich viel Zeit haben, weil der Compiler, wenn der beides kompilieren muss, man so richtig langsam ist.
Ach, mit den hier, mit den, weiß ich nicht, acht Kernen oder so, also das ist jetzt überhaupt, weiß ich nicht, der macht halt in 30 Sekunden, macht ja hier, weiß ich nicht, 400 Quellcode-Dateien.
Nee, also Swift, Swift ist immer noch nicht fertig, also das Gefühl habe ich durchaus, dass es irgendwie, da geht es noch weiter und da geht es wahrscheinlich auch in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit noch weiter und die Tools, die sind halt so, dann zeigt der Debugger ab und an nichts an. Jetzt habe ich einen Fall gefunden, wie man den Compiler ganz so macht.
Wann wurde Swift jetzt vorgestellt? War es wirklich letzten Sommer oder schon das Jahr davor?
Zum WWDC letzten Sommer.
Also wirklich, er ist irgendwie so acht Monate alt, ja?
Es ist jetzt neun Monate, bald wird es geboren.
Also ich, ja, also ja, kann man wahrscheinlich, also gut, benutzt das produktiv oder nur so zum Spaß?
Produktiv heißt, ob ich mit Swift eine App im Store habe? Nein, das nicht. Also ich kenne Leute, die das haben, aber nee.
Gut, weil, ja, also wir haben ungefähr, was hat die App jetzt, irgendwie, okay, ich weiß nicht, 80, 90.000 Zeilen oder so, schätze ich mal.
Wie viele Klassen ungefähr?
Ein paar hundert, sagen zwei, drei hundert.
Nee, das ist natürlich, wenn du ein großes Projekt hast, dann fängst du nicht an, das meistens alles weg, aber du fängst an, es schnell umzuspähen.
Genau, deswegen, und die andere Sache ist, also bei Programmiersprachen bin ich mittlerweile so, wenn, okay, du hast immer irgendwo Komplexität und kannst natürlich Dinge falsch und richtig machen. Ich habe in letzter Zeit durchaus auch Java schätzen gelernt, so mit ordentlichem Tool-Support und da kann man halt wenigstens, also in Java kann man halt jetzt zumindest auf Sprachebene nicht so viel machen, was halt keiner versteht oder was die meisten nicht verstehen, da sind sie plus, plus ist es da genau umgekehrt. Da hast du ja, da hast du ja, da kann man wenig machen, was andere Leute noch verstehen. Da sind die Generics, nee, kann man auch, aber da sind, das ist ja der Compiler sozusagen mit dem, also Templates sind ja Touring-Complete, so und nee, deswegen schätze ich das dann, ich sag mal, bisschen Haskell auch gemacht. Da hat man halt einen Haufen Sprachkonzepte, so die man erstmal auch durchdringen muss, um das Leben auch einfacher zu machen, aber jetzt bei, weiß ich nicht, also bei Swift, wenn ich mir jetzt eine neue Programmiersprache wählen sollte, ob ich da jetzt gerade Swift nehmen würde, das bezweifle ich eigentlich, außer ja gut, dass man dann, ich sag mal, der einzige Grund dafür wäre, dass die Alternative Objective-Sea ist, wäre der einzige Grund, Swift zu benutzen. Ansonsten, ja, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich meine, es ist definitiv nicht so ein Monster-WC++, obwohl es Operatoren hat, die man überladen kann und obwohl es Generics hat. Mit den Operatoren, ja, da gibt es auch Leute, die auf GitHub auch schon ganz fiese Dinge damit gemacht haben. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es ja was, was man nicht unbedingt benutzen muss. Und das war ja damals bei C++ auch schon die Diskussion, ab wann ist es sinnvoll, einen überladenden Operator zu haben. Also das ist so...
Ja gut, bei C++ hat es halt auch 20 Jahre gedauert, bis man gewusst hat, wie man es benutzt.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, bei Swift dauert das dann nicht so lange. Also obwohl da noch einiges an Potenzial drinsteckt.
Also ich habe jedenfalls das Gefühl, also das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr, die Programmiersprachen, sondern die ganzen Apis, die ich gezwungen bin, hier zu benutzen. Also ich hasse das, wenn ich irgendwie so Apis benutzen muss, wo ich dann um Bugs rum programmieren muss, die sich halt einfach anfühlen, also fühlen sich halt nicht solide an.
Ja, aber das hast du bei Apis doch immer.
Nee, also zum Beispiel hab ich das Gefühl, so was, was Sun damals ursprünglich gemacht hat, das war super, später bei Java, aber so oder so rum. Wenn ich jetzt POSIX-Appis benutze, dann weiß ich, also das fühlt sich aber auch, weil ich mein, da...
Ja, aber das ist so 70er.
Ja, aber das ist so niedlich.
Das ist doch eine andere Quantität, die du da vergleist. Also ich meine, wie groß ist die POSIX-Appi?
Ja.
Und wie lange gibt es die Show, um ausgereift zu sein? Und wie viele Bugs finden die da immer noch?
Genau. Aber selbst sowas wie OpenGL zum Beispiel, ist eine relativ fette Appi, aber also fühlt sich immer noch tausendmal solider an als dieser ganze Crap.
Aber ist es nicht genau OpenGL, wo sie gerade neu machen, um da mal den ganzen Schund, wie sie selber geschrieben haben, irgendwie mal aufzubauen, das so noch mal so streamlinen und so?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen. Das stimmt, aber es ist trotzdem...
Ja gut, aber der Vergleich ist natürlich ein bisschen unfair, wenn du eine UI-API mit so was wie einer 3D-API oder irgendwas, was nur Kommandozeile ist, was so POSIX ist, halt Files aufmachen und Threads aufmachen und dann war's das schon. Mehr ist POSIX ja nicht. Keine Ahnung, ich hab mir schon lange nicht mehr so was wie Qt oder Motiv oder Xorg angeguckt, aber ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass dieses Next Step und Folgende relativ solide war in den Konzepten. Klar gibt es da die Probleme, was ich immer gerne anführe, sind die Tableviews mit ihren Data-Sources, die einfach ganz gruselig sind.
Auf OST jetzt, du meinst die Alten, ja oder meinst du auch auf dem iPhone, das ist vom iOS.
Insofern dynamischer, als dass sich in der Datenbank ständig irgendwas ändern kann. Also praktisch jede Tabelle kann, während du sie anguckst, können da Elemente neu auftauchen oder verschwinden.
Ja genau, das ist halt auch das Problem.
So und das funktioniert bei uns auch, aber es ist halt trotzdem pain in the ass. Und da merkt man einfach, obwohl es dafür eigentlich genau gedacht ist, dass es alles nicht vernünftig funktioniert. Aber auf Jahre ist es jetzt auch nicht wirklich besser so. Und am Ende, eigentlich ist das Konzept ganz gut gedacht, dass man halt, das ist schon, dass das das Performant ist. Aber am Ende, so zusammen dann mit Auto-Layout, hatten wir unter iOS 7, gab es da ganz furchtbare Effekte, dann wo er dann anfing.
Du hast das wahrscheinlich unter iOS 6 noch nicht versucht, oder?
Nee, das war klar, dass das halt da noch gar nicht geht. Und dann, ja, mit iOS 7 haben wir halt dann das erste, also haben wir mal mit Constraints, meine ich, jetzt so.
Und das ging dann, aber da hat sich dann regelmäßig der Constraints-Holver irgendwie in Zustand, hat dann ewig Dinge gelöst so mit, also komische Rekursionen, die er da veranstaltet hat. Ja, also furchtbar. Und dann hat man halt immer wieder Probleme, die treten halt unter bestimmten, also manchmal wird halt auf diesen Geräten einfach das Netzwerk total langsam. Und du weißt nicht, warum. So. Rebooteste ist es wieder schnell. So. Und das hat auch, also der ganze HTTP-Stack irgendwie ist, den hab ich in Verdacht oder irgendwo im IP-Stack ist irgendwas kaputt bei den Geräten. Da bin ich seit längerem schon versuche ich rauszufinden, was da abgeht. Aber dann ist halt auch noch die Scheiße, dann Apple mit seinem, wo sie dann ihre ganzen Apis auch noch auszensieren, die ganzen paranoiden Arschlöcher, statt irgendwie den Sans-Goth einfach ins Netz zu stellen, dass du halt da wenigstens mitdebuggen kannst. Also es sackt eigentlich. Wenn Android jetzt nicht noch mehr sacken würde...
Ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass dieses iOS halt so den Weg des gloriosen Browsers geht. Du bist halt im App Store überhaupt nicht mehr in der Lage, mit Software, die du einfach so zum Verkauf anbietest, Geld zu machen. Sondern eigentlich sind dir die meisten Sachen, die da draußen sind, nur ein Frontend für irgendeinen Web-Service. Und insofern ist es ein glorifizierter Browser. Und das ist eigentlich total schade, weil die in dem Gerät so viel mehr drinstecken könnte.
Ja, aber du darfst ja total vieles...
Die eine Hälfte darfst du nicht, und für die andere Hälfte gibt es keinen Markt. Das ist echt irgendwie...
Na ja, gut.
Und dann gibt es halt noch Schlumpfbeeren-Spiele. Und dazwischen ist halt fast nichts.
Also, es ist traurig. Es ist einfach nur traurig, dass wir jetzt Multisensorische Supercomputer in der Tasche haben.
Und sonst haben wir nichts davon.
Und gleichzeitig, ja, die Möglichkeiten, was Geiles damit zu machen, immer mehr beschnitten werden. Bei Android hast du wieder das Problem, da hast du halt, weiß ich nicht, 4.500 verschiedene Devices oder so, die du supporten musst.
Bei uns in der Firma kam neulich so die Mail rum, die Produktmanager haben sich entschlossen, wir können jetzt iOS 6 fallen lassen. Und dann fragte einer der Android-Entwickler nach, und wie sieht es mit Android 1.6 aus? Ne, noch nicht so bald.
1.6? 2.3 wahrscheinlich.
Uralt-Version.
Das ist, wie gesagt, ganz schlimm. Und dann hast du halt wirklich Bugs, die nur beim bestimmten Hersteller auftreten. Und so, und dann, ja, dann die Bildschirme hast du halt überall, sieht halt überall anders aus, die Farben, die du auswählst auf Android. Also es hat so unterschiedliche Displays und Display-Qualitäten. Also das ist das eine, also das Hauptproblem bei Android, halt die ganze Fragmentierung. Aber auch, dass die Hardware, also wenn du halt auf dem...
Aber das ist nicht von den 4000 Geräten oder wie viele auch mal es gibt, es ist nämlich schon, dass irgendwie 90% von Android läuft so auf 10 verschiedenen Geräten. Könnte man das so sagen, oder ist das auch nicht so wichtig?
Ja, wir haben, klar, du kannst halt, also wir haben, glaube ich...
Es gibt nicht irgendwie Samsung und die Google Phones, wobei Google Phone 20 sind gar nicht so viele, ne?
Also wir haben so 15, 20 Geräte, glaube ich, auf denen wir testen.
Und die habt ihr alle da und das muss auch einer machen. Das kostet ja auch ordentlich Zeit, oder?
Ja, wir haben halt mehrere hausinterne Tester und Testplan und die müssen dann hier auf jedem Gerät einmal den Testplan 3-5 Stunden...
Wie viele automatisierte Tests macht ihr so?
Gar nicht.
Überhaupt nicht? Also bei uns gibt es immerhin so eine Art Scripting-Framework, was, so ein simuliert Touches und fährt einmal so den, weiß ich nicht, Test durch, aber der dauert, glaube ich, so ein Regression-Test, glaube ich, dauert 5 Stunden oder so?
Also, wie gesagt, wir hatten es eigentlich seit einem Jahr auf dem Plan, mal irgendwie Automatisierung. Also wir haben ein bisschen Testautomatisierung, aber im Vergleich zu dem Testplan covert das fast nichts. Also der Punkt ist auch, solche Bugs wie irgendwas geht gar nicht oder so haben wir eigentlich fast nicht. Sondern wenn da Bugs sind, dann irgendwo, dann weiß ich nicht. Also die sind meistens subtiler, die Bugs, die wir da haben. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und automatisch auch oft gar nichts zu erkennen, beziehungsweise der Aufwand wäre gewaltig. Klar, Ziel ist es nach wie vor, aber der Aufwand mittlerweile, wenn man das nicht von Anfang an konsequent gleich mitzieht, das später nochmal wirklich ordentlich drüber zu rollen, ist...
Das Geile ist ja immer, wenn wir einen neuen Tester haben, findet der Bugs, die irgendwie schon seit einigen Versionen drin sind. Weil die alten Tester, die nicht mehr finden.
Betriebsblind ist es dann, man kennt sich zu gut aus und weiß schon genau, was man klicken muss. Eigentlich müsste man Tester alle vier Wochen entlassen und frischer einstellen.
So, wollen wir noch ein bisschen Shopping machen?
Ja, ich will jetzt.
Mach mal, ich bitte aber langsam, mein Nikotin-Level ist...
Ja, wir sind jetzt ja auch gleich durch. Wir gehen jetzt ins Finale. Ich erzähle noch ein bisschen was über iPhone-Zubehör und Dennis erzählt noch ein bisschen was über... Eine Waage.
Ich erzähle noch was über ein Spiel und über einen Kommandezahlen-Tour.
Wer zuerst? Also, weil ich ja in letzter Zeit zu viel abgenommen habe und mein Gewicht halten muss. Na, mein Bundesligatrainer hat mir gesagt, wenn ich in der Oberliga im Schwergewicht mitmachen will, muss ich noch ein bisschen zulegen, wisst ihr, wie das immer ist. Man trinkt viel, damit man, wenn man sich auf die Waage stellt, irgendwie die 80 Kilo erreicht. Ich bin immer, das schaffst du mal knapp nicht. Nee, nee, Spaß beiseite. Also, ich hab mir, um, wie sagt man so schön diplomatisch, um mein Gewicht besser kontrollieren zu können, oder nicht mal kontrollieren, so besser im Überblick zu haben, so könnte man es erstmal sagen, habe ich mir mal eine Waage gekauft, weil ich wollte mal wieder ein Gadgetspielzeug haben, weil ich kaufe, ehrlich gesagt, relativ selten Gadgetspielzeuge und die Waage würde ich mal als eine solche betrachten. Welche? Und zwar habe ich mir von, ist eine französische Firma, ich weiß nicht, wie man es genau ausspricht in Englisch, würde ich mal Withings sagen, W-I-T-H-I-N-G-S.
Eine französische Firma?
Echt? Und jetzt sag mir mal, wie man das in Französisch aussprechen soll. Wer hat Vorschläge? Haben wir keinen, der sich damit...
Das ist nicht Französisch.
Guck nach. Guck nach, ist eine französische Firma.
So, das will ich auf Französisch, wenn ich das versuche, auf Französisch auszusprechen, da werde ich gleich festgenommen.
Ist egal. Ist jedenfalls eine Firma, die so, ich glaube, die haben mit den Wagen auch angefangen. Jedenfalls ist es eine Waage, die nicht nur wiegt. Also sie hat so ein kleines LC.
Welche Waage?
Na, wo gibt es nur die?
Den WS50 Smart Body Analyzer meinst du?
Genau, den. Gibt es auch die kleine. Ich habe die 50er. Es gibt auch noch die kleine 30er. Also sie wiegt diese 50er-Version. Sie wiegt mich. Also stellt sie drauf, sie wiegt, zeigt das auf so Matrix-Display schön an. Mit beleuchtet. Genau, die in schwarz, ja.
Mit so einem komischen LCD-Anzeiger.
Genau, also sie wiegt dich. Dann misst sie über die, was ist das dann auch? Impedanz über deine Füße, irgendwie dein Body Fat Percentage. Dann misst sie noch deinen Puls. Und außerdem misst sie noch die Raumtemperatur und auch noch den CO2-Gehalt.
Ist klar, wenn es wärmer ist, wiegst du weniger.
Entschuldigung, ich kann gar nicht ahnen, dass für dich hier gleich so eine furchtbare Werbung kommt.
Erst so ein verquerter Joke und dann auch noch Werbung.
Ja, aber ich bin ja noch nicht fertig. Also diese Waage ist ja halt, da die Daten, die werden ja auch nicht einfach nur so angezeigt, sondern das wär ja ein bisschen langweilig, weil hätte ich mir auch nur normale Waage holen können und Temperatur und alles, kann ich mir auch irgendwie anders anzeigen lassen, eine Funkuhr zum Beispiel oder so. Sondern die Waage schickt die Daten halt, also du hast die am Ende in einer App auf deinem Phone. So, und das Coole daran ist, was ich fand, du packst die Waage aus, die kommt so nach Hause in so einem relativ flachen Karton. Also Apple ist ja auch sehr knapp immer mit den Kartons inzwischen. Der Karton war auch kaum größer als diese Waage, packst du so aus, da ist also eine ganz kleine Mini-Anleitung dabei. Also Mini war die nicht, aber es steht nicht viel drin, so in großen Bildern. Du musst da irgendwie so einen komischen Streifen rausziehen, dann sind wahrscheinlich die Batterien aktiviert, damit sich die vorher nicht leer saugen. Viermal AA sind da drinnen, unten drunter, ist ganz flach das Ding. Und dann geht die sozusagen an, geht in so einen Bluetooth-Pairing-Mode. Dann gehst du in dein iPhone, also du hast auch noch keine App installiert, kein gar nichts, sondern nimmst einfach dein Telefon aus der Tasche, weil das Ding sagt, du sollst das machen. Dann pairsst du das mit deinem Telefon erst mal, also das Telefon sieht automatisch die Waage, du pairsst das. Dann sagt die Waage dem Telefon über dieses Bluetooth-Dings irgendwie ja hier. Und zwar, du musst da folgende App runterladen, und dann fragt sich das Telefon, willst du das machen? Dann sagst du einfach nur Yes. Das heißt, du musst auch diese App nicht suchen, dann wird dir alles automatisch angeboten. Klickst du drauf, dann fragt er dich ja hier mit der Waage und so, sagst du Yes, Yes, Yes. Und dann sagt er noch, naja, ob die Waage jetzt die WLAN-Daten von deinem Telefon kriegen soll, also den Namen und das passende Passwort dazu. Und dann sagst du auch Yes. Und dann kennt die Waage das WLAN und das Passwort und hat automatisch Netz. Dann hat die Waage angefangen, sich automatisch erstmal ein Update runterzuladen, hat sich erstmal geflasht. Und dann, irgendwie nochmal eine Minute später, war die Waage fertig und meinte so ready und ich könnte mich jetzt da drauf stellen. Habe ich gemacht, hat sie halt gemessen, Puls gemessen und so weiter, hat das in meine App hochgeladen.
Hier kommt selber eine Zahl.
Ich bin bei, ne, sage ich nicht. Doch, ich bin bei 104 Kilo und bin viel zu schwer.
Viel nicht, aber zu schwer.
Ist auch.
Probier es mal mit Laufen.
Ich bin aber auch nicht klein, so. Aber nicht so groß wie Hokey und der leichter ist. MMM, jedenfalls gibt es von Withings eine App, die heißt, wie heißt die eigentlich? Ich muss kurz mal selbst gucken hier. Die heißt Healthmade, glaube ich, genau. Obwohl da unter dem Namen steht nur Withings. Aber intern nennt sie sich Healthmade. So und die protokolliert jetzt alle Daten mit. Also man muss dazu sagen, die Waage schickt jedes Mal, wenn ich mich drauf stelle, schickt jetzt per WLAN die Daten zu Withings hoch, wo automatisch für mich auch mit der App ein Account erstellt wurde. Das heißt, ich war nie auf der Webseite, sondern das hat die App gemacht. Und wenn ich die App starte, die App holt sich die Daten wiederum auch von Withings wieder zurück. Wenn man das nicht möchte, per WLAN oder wenn man keinen WLAN hat, dann kann die Waage auch die Daten ans Telefon direkt per Bluetooth schicken. Das macht das auch alles von ganz selber. Man muss nichts aktivieren oder die App soll wohl im Hintergrund laufen, aber das tat sie bisher wohl immer. Jedenfalls merkt sich die Waage und schickt das aufs Telefon. Wenn man auch nicht da ist, dann merkt sie sich auch die Temperatur. Die wird ja öfter gemessen als nur dann, wenn du dich draufstellst, sondern die ganze Zeit und CO2-Gehalt auch. Das sammelt die und schickt das von alleine alle 14 Stunden irgendwie per WLAN oder per Bluetooth an dein Telefon. Und so läuft das. Der Frank Rieger hat auch so eine Waage. Und der hat mir schon gesagt, er hat schon auf seinem Router, in einer Host-Datei, hat er einfach die Adresse von Withings bei sich eingetragen, sodass sich die Waage jetzt einfach bei ihm meldet. Der hat das sozusagen abgefangen. Und die Waage versucht, zwar HTTPS zu sprechen, wenn aber auf der Gegenseite kein HTTPS ist. Was macht die Waage? Na? Wir wollen ja Service haben, da muss natürlich immer alles funktionieren. Also sie macht Fallback auf normal 80 und macht dann kein HTTPS mehr. Genau, und da drin ist dann halt irgendwie so Daten in JSON, meinte Frank. Und da kann man die dann mitschneiden, wenn man das nicht möchte, dass das zu Withings hochgeht. Dann muss man sich aber auch sein eigenes GUI und irgendwelche Anzeigen dann selber coden und so weiter und so fort. Und was noch witzig ist, das kann ich euch ja hier mal vorführen. Für den Vorführeffekt, die Waage, da die ja auch den Puls misst, hat die hier so ein Feature, dass man hier bei Puls macht, das muss ich mal da hingehen, da sage ich hier, ich möchte eine neue Messung machen, add new measurement, da steht so ein Startbutton, dann mache ich meinen Finger hinten auf den Sensor drauf, dann klicke ich hier drauf und dann geht jetzt gleich der Blitz an dauerhaft, also die LED geht an und beleuchtet meinen Finger und durch die Blutmenge, die jetzt da durchpulst, misst er jetzt meinen Puls, weil das Rot, was jetzt an der Kamera ankommt, die Widerspiegelung von meinem Finger, ist jetzt mein Puls, wie du hier so lang laufen siehst und das sind jetzt 90 Grad, weil ich quatsche gerade so viel. Da ist ein bisschen höher und jetzt hat er meinen Puls gemessen. Schon witzig, oder?
Ja, also die Appstore ist voll mit solchen Apps, die genau das so machen.
Hat man noch nicht. Genau, ich auch noch nicht und habe das auch nicht gewusst und ich fand das eigentlich voll witzig.
Das funktioniert aber nicht ordentlich, wenn man eine Hülle hat.
Also ich habe eine Hülle und das funktioniert sehr ordentlich.
Na vielleicht funktioniert es nicht in der roten Hülle.
Ich mache das immer so, dass ich meinen Finger drauf lege, aber ich drücke ihn eigentlich gar nicht auf der Linse, sondern ich lasse ihn nur so auf der Hülle liegen. Der schwebt sozusagen so einen Millimeter über der Linse. Vielleicht ist das der Trick, keine Ahnung. Weil ich dachte, mit aufdrücken ist es ja wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also alle Pulsmesser funktionieren im Prinzip so. Ich habe ja dieses Teil am Armband, weil ich irgendwie beim Laufen die ganze Zeit ja...
Der macht das ja nicht mit Licht, oder?
Doch, klar. Wie die Apple Watch auch. Die haben unten so LEDs, die leuchten dann in dich rein.
Und die Wiederspiele und Reflektierungen davon messen sie halt.
Weil das Blut halt immer so hin und her pulst, dann kannst du daraus optisch das einfach messen.
Ich denke mal, das ist halt... Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Rotstufen der Sensor jetzt wirklich hat. Ob es 256 sind, so wie er später im Bild rauskommt, oder ob der dann sogar mehr hat, wenn du da raw rankommst. Und dann wisst du einfach, wann es heller und dunkler wird.
Okay, also jedenfalls, gut. Steht jetzt dein Gewicht, aber ist quasi pseudonym. Also eigentlich wissen sie jetzt...
Nee, ich hab sogar meine Daten angegeben. Aber könnte man machen.
Mehr Aluhut wagen.
Was man noch machen könnte, wenn man jetzt noch mal ein bisschen ins Detail geht, angenommen, man ist jetzt eine große Family. Und angenommen, meine Freundin würde jetzt genauso viel wiegen... Ach so, genau, die Waage erkennt einen, auch wenn du dich draufschaltst. Sie weiß halt, ich wiege 104 Kilo, ich stelle mich drauf und sie sagt, hallo Dennis, mehr oder weniger, sie zeigt den Namen an. Wenn jetzt meine Freundin, was nicht der Fall ist, genauso viel wiegt wie ich, dann würde die Waage sagen, ja, alles klar, bist du Dennis oder bist du jemand anderes? Und dann kann man mit dem Wippen, mit dem Fuß, links oder rechts kann man sagen, wer man ist, damit die Waage halt Bescheid weiß. Ja, genau. Und man kann sozusagen diese mehreren Personen mit einer iPhone-App irgendwie verwalten. Man kann aber auch, wenn eine andere Person, angenommen Pavel jetzt hätte auch, würde sich diese App installieren, dann könnte er zu mir nach Hause kommen, könnte sehen, ah, guck mal, der Dennis, der hat ja die gleiche Waage, wie sagen wir, du hättest die auch bei dir zu Hause. Und dann könntest du meine Waage bei dir addieren in deiner App. Und wenn du dich dann draufstellst, würde die Waage dann dich auch erkennen. Das kann man mit bis zu zehn Leuten machen. Und dann weiß die Waage, alles klar, diese Daten gehören jetzt dem, und diese Daten gehören dem. Und dann kann man das unterscheiden. Dann kann man sozusagen mehrere Wagen, also man kann mehrere Wagen in seiner App irgendwie sich konfigurieren. Und dann kennen die sich untereinander. Und dann kann man sich auch woanders wiegen, wenn man will. Ich weiß, wer ich überreden meine. Das stimmt. Was ich immer mache, mein Standard ist, dass ich mich immer in Unterhose und T-Shirt wiege. Aber natürlich Socken aus, weil sonst geht das mit dem Bodyfat-Percentage und mit dem Puls nicht. Nee, die bleiben einfach drin. Habe ich mich aber auch schon gefragt, warum man nicht noch so ein Offset bei Withings angeben kann, dass man sagt, ich wiege mich eigentlich immer mit diesen Klamotten an, die wiegen ja so viel, und die werde ich gerne bitte abgezogen. Aber das ist ja 0,1 Prozent oder was? Das ist ja bei dem Gewicht egal.
Ich muss sagen zu dem Thema wiegen, dass ich halt auch seit ungefähr, weiß nicht, zwischen 30 und 40 Jahren das Gefühl habe eigentlich zu viel zu wiegen.
Du hast so ein Gefühl, Pavel.
Ich habe schon ganz viele Gefechte ausgefochten über mehrere Jahre lang, um irgendwie mein Gewicht zu kontrollieren. Mittlerweile bin ich aber der Meinung, für Wagen gibt es zwei Hauptanwendungsfälle, wenn man schwanger oder wenn man krank ist, halte ich es für sinnvoll. Also krank in dem Sinne, dass man irgendwie eine Krankheit hat, die eine Gewichtskontrolle erfordert. Also sozusagen zu medizinischen Zwecken. Alles andere ist jetzt, um quasi sein Körpergewicht zu kontrollieren, braucht man jetzt keine Waage.
Manche machen das halt so vom Gefühl, die Hose passt halt nicht mehr. Aber das ist ja ja so schleichend, das kriegt man ja so langsam nicht mit. Ist man beim nächsten Mal eine Hose kaufen, nimmt man intuitiv halt die nächste Größe und dann war mir doch egal, welche ich beim letzten Mal hatte, dann fällt das nichts auf. Aber ich verstehe, was man so macht.
Also mein Körpergewicht schwankt auch temperaturabhängig um mehrere Kilo, weil je nachdem, wie warm es ist, umso mehr Wasser lagert man ein oder aus und zwischen morgens und abends und so.
Ja, und auch was du am Vorabend gegessen hast.
Ja, aber das ist ja eben das Schöne, dass man hier halt einen Grafen kriegt, der das einem über die Zeit zeigt. Und dann gehen diese ganzen Unregelmäßigkeiten eigentlich darunter und dann hat man eine schöne Linie und dann sieht man schon den Trend sozusagen.
Ja, wenn das über eine Woche mittels geht, eigentlich.
Eine Woche reicht, glaube ich. Ich habe jetzt drei und ja.
Ja, also ich habe das, ich habe mal, glaube ich, für 20 Euro irgendwie im Supermarkt eine Digitalwaage ohne Bluetooth-Anbindung vor. Ja, und habe dann halt, hatte dann halt eine Liste oder eine Excel-Tabelle, in die ich das mal eingetragen hatte. Also früher damals, weil ohne Mittel tatsächlich bringst du es überhaupt nicht, deswegen hatte ich gerade mal kurz überlegt, ob mich das dazu bringen könnte. Ja, was willst du machen, wenn irgendwie die Werte dort, ja, ich meine, klar, kannst natürlich hungern.
Ja, ich, klar, ist ja auch nur erstmal ein technisches Spielzeug und man kann damit...
Okay, also bist du zufrieden?
Ich bin erstmal zufrieden. Was ich noch, was ich vergessen habe zu erwähnen, ist, dass die App natürlich auch die Daten an Hellskid weiterreicht und auch andersrum, weil Hellskid ist ja auch so ein Datensammler, kann ich dieser App zum Beispiel erlauben, dass es von Hellskid meine täglichen Schritte und Kilometer holt oder auch meine Größe, weil da kann man ja alle möglichen Sachen einstellen und dann hat die Withings App das auch und sagt mir, ey, du bist hier, weil die machen da so ein bisschen auf Gesundheit und sagen, ey, hier, du bist diesen Freitag so wenig gelaufen wie noch nie und du musst hier mehr gehen und die versucht einen so zu animieren, dass man mal ein bisschen was tut. Ob das klappt, ist noch eine andere Sache, aber man kann, also alle Daten landen auch in diesem Hellskid mit drin und da wird es auch nochmal angezeigt und zusammengesammelt und ich habe mich da vorher noch nie mit beschäftigt eigentlich und finde es, also klar von der Gläser, Überwachung würde ich jetzt nicht nennen, aber dass die so alle Daten sammeln, ist natürlich schon so ein bisschen, muss man aufpassen, aber an sich finde ich das gut, wenn ich die meine Daten, wenn es dann meine bleiben, alle da so sammeln kann. Ob es dann meine bleiben, ist jetzt so die Frage.
Genau, vielstens dann, wenn dann der, der 10 oder 20 Prozent Rabatt von einer Krankenversicherung kommt, wenn du dich an den vorgegebenen Trainingsplan hältst.
Da warten wir wirklich alle drauf.
Was ein bisschen schade ist, was ich auch mit dem Frank Rieger bequatscht habe, dieses Health-Kit ist ja eigentlich eine ganz coole Geschichte, weil alle möglichen Programme können da ihre Daten reinschmeißen. Also auch irgendwie, wenn du deinen Blutzucker misst und so, kann man auch alles möglich an Daten reinpumpen und du kriegst da so schöne Graphen angezeigt. Was ein bisschen schade fanden ist, weil die Waage ja auch Temperatur und CO2-Gehalt macht. Und das sind ja nun keine Gesundheitswerte. Die kann man halt eben nicht in Health-Kit reinpumpen und man kriegt schöne Graphen angezeigt. Eigentlich wäre cool, wenn man das nicht nur Health-Kit hätte, sondern grundsätzlich so Data- oder Graphen-Kit, wo man sagt, ich habe ja immer Temperatur, das ist Feuer in der Raum, oder woher auch immer, irgendein Motor, ist ja total egal, kann man sich selber aussuchen. Ja, aber gibt es ja noch nicht. Also das hätten wir gerne noch, weil so Daten reinpumpen, die über Zeit so sich gesammelt werden und angezeigt werden.
Es gibt bei Health-Kit halt auch das Problem, in Anführungszeichen, dass Apple vorgibt, was für Daten du sammeln kannst, und du kannst keine eigenen Felder hinzufügen.
Ja, denke aber, das kommt dann wahrscheinlich auch noch. Also, wenn das mit dem Home-Kit geht, könnte ich mir schon gut vorstellen, dass da auch noch andere Sachen kommen. Ich meine, das ist doch, wenn noch Apple so viel sammeln will und einem das anbieten will und einfacher machen will.
Naja, sie wollen ja nicht nur ein Data-Storage sein, dass du da deine Daten hast, sondern sie wollen diese Daten ja auch explizit typisieren und klassifizieren können.
Genau, und wenn du nicht bei, also genau, da musst du schon irgendwie Vorgaben machen.
Ja, wenn ich sage, ich will hier nur Temperatur, ist folgender Raum, mach ich mir ein eigenes Kommentarfeld, die Zeit ist ja automatisch und die sagt, die Einheit ist ja zelsus, also was gibt's da groß falsch zu machen?
Wir werden sehen, wenn HomeKit da ist. So, ich hab jetzt auch noch hier was. Und zwar bin ich darauf hingewiesen worden, also genau, bevor ich es erstmal vergesse, hier die Leckereien, die wir da gerade verspeist haben, sowohl das Bier als auch die Toffee-Fee, kommen von Petra und Udo, die uns das schon zur letzten Sendung geschickt haben, wegen des William... Ich hatte das Paket zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht erhalten, weil das halt beim Nachbarn abgegeben wurde und das dann halt nicht mehr rechtzeitig den Weg zu mir fand. So ist das mit manchen Paketen, deswegen ist hier manches...
Ich muss mich jetzt ganz kurz einklingen, geht ganz schnell. Ich hab auch, weil wir haben über Messer geredet und ich meinte, ich bräuchte mal so richtig geiles Brötchenmesser, hat mir einer gleich geschrieben, mit dem ich schon mal so Austausch hatte, ja hier hat er, er schickt mir welche, kam an, von Victorinox, so mit Plastikgriff, so ganz dünne Klingen mit Wellenschliff. Ja, scheiße scharf, schneiden Brötchen richtig gut, aber irgendwann habe ich nicht richtig aufgepasst und bang, ich habe geblutet wie Sau. Also das ist nichts für den Kindertisch, wirklich. Die sind so schweinescharf und diese Wellen sind wirklich, und das ist so schmal, also das ist wirklich eine ganz dünne Klinge. Sie biegt sich auch bei harter Butter relativ schnell, aber es ist scheiße scharf und ich finde fast, das ist für den, wenn man morgens noch nicht ganz wach ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das so das Wahre ist. Aber trotzdem vielen Dank natürlich.
Ja, passenden Gesundheitstipp zu generell, weil sich in letzter Zeit, also Zinkoxidsalbe beschleunigt extrem die Wundheilung.
Ich hab das fünf Minuten meinen Arm hochgehalten, damit es nicht mehr so läuft und dann hat es aufgehört und dann war zugetrocknet und fertig.
Ja, aber dann spürst du es halt, also trotzdem ja. Ich kann nur, wie gesagt, kann das nur empfehlen, weil ich hatte halt auch eine Schnittwunde, aber das ist aber was anderes und ja, egal, gut. Ja, also genau, dann machen wir weiter. Ich bin hier durch, weil ich hätte...
Ja, es gibt nichts, was hier nicht reinpasst.
Ja, ich hätte, ja und ansonsten hatte ich halt tatsächlich auch noch sozusagen so eine, auch wirklich, ich bin ja eher so ein Medikamentenskeptiker. Das heißt, also so bevor ich anfange, irgendwelche Medikamente zu nehmen. Aber kein Impfgegner. Nein, ich habe aber auf meinem Blog habe ich zu dem Impfthema mal einiges geschrieben, auch wie das...
Auf pavelmayer.de?
Ja, da ist es mittlerweile, damals war es noch auf Aggregat 7 so. Und da ist, ja ist wie gesagt etwas älter, musst du es mal irgendwie nach Impfen oder so suchen. Ich schreibe, aber ich veröffentliche es im Moment nicht, weil irgendwie werde ich nicht richtig fertig damit. Und zwar, was halt manchmal helfen kann, so wenn man irgendwelche akuten Entzündungen hat, manchmal so was weiß ich, Zahnfleisch oder irgendwie sowas, wo denkt, okay jetzt irgendwie, ja, gibt es halt so eine Kombination, die irgendwie zumindest bei mir funktioniert hat und die wohl auch bei anderen funktioniert hat, die Kombination aus Bromelain und Zinkorotat. Und zwar Bromelain ist so ein Enzym, was auch in der Ananas vorkommt und das wirkt halt einfach entzündungshemmend. Problem ist halt nur, wenn du Ananas isst, wird das halt durch die Magensäure zerstört und das gibt es halt eben in so einer Variante, halt rezeptfrei in einer Apotheke, wo es halt dann den Magensaft überlebt. Und Zinkorotat ist im Prinzip auch so im Prinzip eine Zinkverbindung und diese Kombination so hilft, ist halt entzündungshemmend und sorgt dafür, dass das halt relativ schnell wieder verheilt. Also es ist wohl im Bereich der Sportmedizin wird das angewendet und das Promellain speziell bei so postoperativ wird das verabreicht, um die Wundheilung zu beschleunigen und eben auch. Vor Weihnachten hatte ich so eine Entzündung, weil ich keine Mandeln mehr habe, und da habe ich das empfohlen gekriegt, dachte mir, okay, jetzt ist irgendwie so ein Ananasenzyme und Zink, das kann jetzt nicht, im schlimmsten Fall wirkt es halt nicht. Ich hatte aber das Gefühl, dass es schon funktioniert hat. Also insofern kann ich es zumindest mal empfehlen, wenn jemand mal jetzt so eine Entzündung hat, einfach mal ausprobieren, ob es hilft, bevor man dann… Klar, wenn man jetzt Fieber hat, würde ich jetzt lieber zum Arzt gehen, aber das Gefühl hat, hier ist irgendwas dick oder… Also ja, bei mir hat es funktioniert, wie gesagt Bromelain und Zinkorotat.
Alles wird gut.
Ja, und es war gut. Hat funktioniert.
Ja, die Wunderheiler-Sendung Freak Show. Ich weiß gar nicht ganz genau, warum, aber irgendjemand hat in den Kommentaren, ich glaube, ich habe in irgendeiner Sendung von dem Glyph gesprochen, diese komische Klammer für das iPhone. G-L-I-F. Die sich ja sozusagen so dediziert um diesen iPhone-Korpus herumdrückt und dann kann man damit das halt klippen und in einen Stativ reinstellen. Und wurde dann korrigiert, dass das ja nicht state of the art wäre, weil was ja total angesagt ist, wäre ja der ShoulderPod. Und den ShoulderPod, den habe ich mir jetzt mal besorgt. Das ist wirklich eine interessante Konstruktion. Ich habe das mal hier in der Hand. Das ist der ShoulderPod. Das ist ein relativ massives Teil, wo man so einen kleinen Rädchen, so zwei Griffklammern, beliebig auf- und zuschrauben kann. Und damit kann man halt sein Telefon fixieren. Zwecks der kontrollierten Aufnahme von Video und Audio.
Also es sieht aus wie eine Schraubzwinge.
Genau, es ist im Prinzip eine Schraubzwinge.
Mit irgendwie einem Benzel dran.
Schraubzwinge, so mit so Gummilippen oben und unten. Und das Gute ist, dass es halt sowohl das Telefon nicht zerkratzt, wenn das Telefon direkt anliegt, aber sich auch eben von Cases und so weiter nicht groß aufhalten lässt.
Und man muss irgendwie aber stundenlang drehen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Na ja, ich denke, wenn du einmal deine Größe gefunden hast. Das Rädchen ist sehr fein. Wie soll ich sagen?
Justiziabel, justierbar.
Genau, also er ist ein sehr feines Gewinde. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut so. Ja, dann hat man das irgendwie so in der Hand.
Okay, also du hast jetzt ein Telefon in so einem Schraubstock und jetzt?
Das ist jetzt so eine Art Selfiestick? Nein.
Kann man natürlich als Selfiestick verwenden, aber vor allem kann ich das halt jetzt... Weil, erstens hat das halt unten so eine Stativschraube. Das heißt, du kannst das so aufs Stativ setzen und dann einfach auf dem Stativ als Videokamera oder Fotokamera benutzen. Aber was halt noch beiliegt, ist so ein kleiner lederbewehrte Schlaufe plus noch mal so ein kleiner Anfasser, den man unten halt quasi als Stativersatz reinschrauben kann. Und dann kannst du das Ding halt einerseits, indem du diese Schlaufe umlegst, irgendwie sicher halten, kann er nicht runterfallen. Und an diesem kleinen Schnupsi kannst du das Ding halt einfach wunderbar halten. Und damit hast du natürlich dann ein 1A, ja, obides Kamerading sieh.
Also was ist jetzt der Hauptanwendungswerk, den du wirklich damit mit deinem iPhone Filme zu machen oder Fotos?
Genau, Fotos und Filme, um halt einfach das Teil stabil zu halten, wenn du es in der Hand halten willst. Du musst halt nicht ums Telefon herumgreifen und hast die Finger vor der Kamera und so weiter. Aber du kannst es halt auch einfach auf Stativ draufsetzen.
Im Prinzip also ein Griff fürs iPhone.
Ein Griff für jedes beliebige Telefon.
Ein Griff fürs iPhone mit Passivgewinde unten dran.
Ein Griff fürs Telefon.
So sieht es aus.
Mit Einspannvorrichtung.
Ein Selfie-Frontend.
Ein ShoulderPod.
Warum Shoulder?
Keine Ahnung.
Kostenpunkt? Das ist schon ganz schön teuer, oder? Es sieht jetzt nicht nach billig Metall aus.
Ja, war aber günstig. Ich glaube, da werden nur 29 Euro für aufgerufen. So sieht es aus.
Aber wenn man jetzt nicht gerade wirklich so einen Stativ hat, macht es jetzt nicht so wirklich viel Sinn, oder? Also ohne Stativ ist es jetzt nicht so der Bringer.
Es ist ja dafür gedacht, es auf einen Stativ... Das ist sozusagen dein Adapter, um dein Telefon auf einen Stativ zu kriegen. Weil wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt so Video-Podcasting machst oder so was und dein Telefon also wirklich als Videokamera benutzt.
Um deine Frage zu beantworten, ja, wenn du keinen Stativ hast, ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so sinnvoll.
Na, wenn du keinen Stativ hast, kannst du immer noch diesen Schnupsi hier unten als Stativersatz ersetzen.
Aber das ist nicht der eigentliche Sinn. Du hast ja mal völlig gesagt, das ist so ein Stativhalter fürs iPhone. Du fängst so haltermäßig an.
Schnupshalter.
Ja, weil ich halt auch diesen Schnupsi ja hat. Und ich finde diesen Schnupsi ehrlich gesagt ganz toll.
Und ich habe neulich übrigens mal etwas länger gefilmt hier mit dem Telefon. Und es ist schon scheiße, wenn man keinen Griff hat.
Und wenn man so ein schmaler Rasierklinger im Telefon hat.
Ja, nee, weil es war außerdem auch kalt. Ich hatte halt kalte Finger. Und dann weißt du nicht, wo du hinpacken sollst. Dann hast du halt, wenn du nicht aufpasst, hast du halt irgendwie ein Finger auch noch vor der Linse und so. Deswegen, ich kann mir das schon gut vorstellen.
Du benutzt das doch mal.
Das ist schon was, was bringt. Also wer jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts für mich war, aber trotzdem.
So sieht es aus.
Zum Film.
Der ShoulderPod, meine Empfehlung.
Was ich immer noch bräuchte, weil ich öfter mal Facetime mache, ich stelle mein Telefon ja mal so schräg hin und lehne das immer irgendwie so an mein Display an, dass ich halt das so stehen habe, damit ich mit Facetime mit irgendjemandem quatschen kann. Wenn aber mein Telefon gerade leer ist, muss ich ja von unten das Kabel reinstecken. Und wenn das Kabel unten drin ist, dann kann es ja nicht mehr so stehen, weil es steht dann auf dem Kabel und fällt dann immer um. Und ich bräuchte was, wo ich das so reinstellen kann, obwohl es irgendwie geladen wird, damit ich Facetime kann. Wahrscheinlich heißt das iPhone-Doc, aber okay. Gibt es die dann für den neuen schon?
Luxusprobleme und First World Problems. Hier bei der Nausolft, bei der Freak Show. Ich glaube, wir sind alle müde und fertig und durch, oder?
Zwei kleine Sachen habe ich noch. Das erste war ein Kommando-Zahlende-Tool, das ich gefunden habe, das nennt sich JQ. Und ist so eine Art JSON-Toolbox. Man pipet da einen JSON rein und kann dann, ähnlich wie bei XPath, einen bestimmten Pfad rausextrahieren. Oder man kann das auch einfach nur, quasi wie ein Beautifier benutzen. Und dann kommt es farbig und ordentlich formatiert hinten wieder raus.
Das heißt, man kann dann einfach da...
Das Ding ist relativ mächtig. Ich kann jetzt nicht im Einzelnen sagen, was das alles tut, weil ich wahrscheinlich auch die ganzen Anwendungen nicht habe. Aber ich fand das mal sehr, sehr spannend. Und dachte mir, das ist ein guter Tipp. Und das Zweite ist ein Spiel, was ich entdeckt habe. Das nennt sich The Vanishing of Ethan Carter. Wer öfter mal zuhört, weiß, dass ich ja so Point-and-Click-Rätsel-Spiele-Adventures mag. Und das ist so eins in der Art, so ein bisschen gruselig. Aber es ist Open World und läuft auf der Unreal Engine 3. Und das ist eine echt krasse Kombination. Man kann da also durch eine riesige Welt laufen und kann da Rätsel lösen. Das ist wirklich so, so was habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Es ist schon eine bedrückende Atmosphäre. The Vanishing of Ethan Carter gibt es leider nur unter Windows.
Weird Fiction Horror.
Weird Fiction Horror, ja, gut. Aber es ist wirklich der Hammer. Das geht schon damit los, dass bei jemandem der Zug über die Füße fährt und relativ viel Blut ist im Einsatz. Das ist schon hammermäßig. Aber es ist eine unheimlich dichte Atmosphäre.
Mit was kann man das jetzt vergleichen, damit sich Leute vielleicht was vorstellen können, wenn man schon was kennt? Was kommt dem ähnlich?
Das ist genau mein Problem. Ich weiß nicht, womit man es vergleichen kann. Es ist dadurch, dass es halt, wie gesagt, es ist halt ein Adventure-Spiel, so ein Grusel-Horror-Ding, aber halt erstens open world. Du kannst da Ewigkeiten durch den Wald rennen. Und es ist halt, naja, es ist so point and click. Du löst halt quasi Fälle, wie sind Leute gestorben.
Wo hast du denn den Windows-Rechner her? Ernsthaft?
Das meinen sie, wo ich meine Elite spiele. Mein Mac Pro macht halt Bootcamp.
Ihr geht fremd.
Ah, die Portierung, genau, die Portierung von Elite ist in Arbeit und braucht Yosemite und irgendwelche Experten meinten schon, das liegt wohl da dran, weil die von Frontier Development wohl auf Quality stehen oder darauf setzen, weil erst bei Yosemite war OpenGL 4.0 so richtig am Start und das brauchst du halt, damit alles schön schick aussieht, weil bei Elite ist alles total schick.
Du, ich hab, weiß ich nicht, den ganzen Tag zugebracht, da irgendwie dieses Windows zum Laufen zu kriegen. Ja, kleiner Tipp am Rande. Wenn du aus gewissen Rechnern das optische Laufwerk ausbaust, kannst du nie wieder irgendwas anderes als Mac OS booten. Weil das UEFI, haste nicht gesehen, nicht so weit in Ordnung ist, dass du irgendwie...
Von externen Windows booten kannst. Windows booten über USB geht nämlich nicht, ne?
Ab einer bestimmten UEFI-Version geht das. Ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, welche Geräte das alles können. Aber es gibt neuere Macs, die das können.
Echt?
Also vorzugsweise die, die kein eingebautes optisches Laufwerk haben. Aber die, die ein eingebautes optisches Laufwerk haben, wenn du das ausbaust, hast du verloren.
Und wenn du das Laufwerk über USB dranhängst, tut es nicht?
Nee, geht nur, wenn es eingebaut ist. Ich glaub mir, ich hab's alles versucht. Der eigentliche Trick war dann, die Partition anzulegen als NTFS-Partition, die gesamte Windows 7 Boot, also diese Installations-CD, so wie sie ist, alle Files auf die Partition zu moveen, sie dann irgendwie bootfähig zu kriegen, davon zu booten und dann in-place des Windows zu installieren. Und dann geht's. Das ist das Einzige, was ich hingekriegt habe. Das war jetzt die Ultrakurzfassung. Gut, aber ich glaube, du hast jetzt keine Hand frei, um die Rausschmeißmusik zu starten, oder?
Meinst du, dass der Zeitpunkt gekommen ist, die Rausschmeißmusik zu starten?
Also von mir aus könntest du das jetzt tun.
Film- oder Musikempfehlungen gibt es keine mehr?
Ich finde, das könnten wir auch mit aufnehmen, weil wir machen ja inzwischen alles, oder? Wir sind ja der Podcast für alle Lebenslagen.
Ich hätte ansonsten noch ein paar Filmempfehlungen aus dem Romance-Genre.
Was ist denn das für ein Genre?
Ich habe auch keine Filmempfehlungen. Romance ist halt das Genre, das nicht irgendwie... Boy meets Girl. Das ist sozusagen, wo es um Beziehungen geht. Liebe und so. Genau, Filme, in die man mit Frauen reingeht, oder sich normalerweise nur Frauen angucken und Männer normalerweise nicht, oder es nicht zugeben zumindest. Und ich hab jetzt tatsächlich einfach jetzt in der letzten Woche irgendwie mal so das Internet nach irgendwie mal in dieses Romance-Genre reingeguckt und hab wirklich, wirklich ein paar großartige Sachen, ich meine gut, die sind ja nicht immer komplett Genre rein, aber sagen ein Film, gut, den kannte ich schon, der passt aber auch nicht nur in Romance rein, sondern das ist, ich weiß nicht, wer von euch den kennt, Scott Pilgrim vs. Ich kenn den nicht. Du kennst den nicht?
Super.
Also Scott Pilgrim vs. The World ist ja einfach, muss man gesehen haben, ist eigentlich eine Comic-Verfilmung, aber ist eine wundervolle Liebesgeschichte, außerdem und auch mit vielen Nerds und so. Also es ist definitiv irgendwie eine großartige Sache. Und das Zweite, was auch großartig ist von 2000...
Das ist aber schon mehr so Nerd-Romance gerade, weil es pekt jetzt nicht unter die übliche Hollywood-Kitsch-Romance.
2010. Naja, der ist trotzdem... also ich fand sehr coole Leute. Und es ist potentiell etwas verwirrend für Leute, die nicht...
Nein, der ist voll cool.
Der ist ziemlich... also so. Und dann gesagt noch, das zweite Ding, was mich umgehauen hat, war The Perks of Being a Wallflower von 2012. Den kenne ich nicht. Ist ein sehr...
also...
ja.
Ach, der ist mit dem Mädel von Harry Potter, ne?
Genau. Emma Watson spielt da genau auch mit. Und ja, eigentlich definitiv so, das waren die zwei absoluten Highlights. Und dann gibt es noch so drei Nebenempfehlungen, die trotz der Titel einfach als Filme mir trotzdem gut gefallen haben. Und ich auch meiner Tochter als Empfehlung. Nämlich einmal The First Time von 2012. Ja, also den Titel nach würde man sich das tatsächlich, aber es ist trotzdem, also trotz des Titels eigentlich, ja.
Romantik-Comedy-Film.
Ja, genau. Dann andere, noch Ten Things I Hate About You von 1999. Ja, möglicherweise.
He's Ledger, ja, der Verstorbene. Und Joseph Gordon-Levitt, wie er heißt, der ist ja ziemlich cool.
He's Ledger, das war doch der Joker.
Der Joker, der dann gestorben ist, genau. Und Joseph Gordon-Levitt ist der von, ja, wie heißt er? Ach, die Schauspieler kennt man da auch. Die hat bei, das war, bei Dexter hat die mitgemacht.
Okay, gut, ich lasse uns da erstmal bei, würde ich sagen.
Hab ich gleich eine Empfehlung für dich, wenn man hier bei Romance ist, hier so mit Nerds oder mit Kids. Der Film heißt Submarine. Die sind aber ein bisschen jünger noch irgendwie. Vielleicht ist auch, ne, Coming of Ages ist noch zu früh, weiß nicht. Ich fand den Film voll witzig, Englisch, glaube ich. Und meine Empfehlung, weil ich den gerade geguckt habe, der ist jetzt aber nicht mehr Romance, es ist ein dänischer Western, genau, der. Er geht irgendwann zu einer Freundin, die er hat, und er will sie haben, und sie sitzt aber gerade mit einem anderen rum, und dann sagt er nur so, are you coming or what? Dann gerade raus. Und sie dann so, no? Und ich fand das sehr gut. Er hat sozusagen alles gegeben und... Er hätte nicht wirkt, es geht ja weiter. Aber die Momente erst mal... Sie hat halt einen anderen neben sich sitzen, und er dachte jetzt, muss er was tun? Ich verrate nichts. Jedenfalls der andere Film, den ich gerade gesehen habe, der mir gefallen hat, der aus der Standardreihe der Hollywood-Filme fällt, ist The Salvation. Das ist ein dänischer Western, den sie in Südafrika gedreht haben, mit Marz Mikkelsen. Aber ich fand ihn, also er ist jetzt wirklich, er ist so wirklich western, wie in den 50er-, 60er-Jahren gedreht worden, so mit diesen Standard-gut-böse-Mann-frau-Tralala-Geschichten. Aber er ist richtig gut gemacht. Und habe ich auch schon da Eveline erzählt, mit dem ich auch schon mit Mara unseren Movie-Podcast gemacht habe, einmal mit Hucke. Da ist die Musik von einem Xavé Maas, der ein Instrument spielt, was Archie Laut heißt. Oder vielleicht weißt du, wie das Ding genau heißt? So ein 12-Seiten-große Gitarre, die sehr bassig ist, sehr tieftönig. Und der macht da die Filmmusik. Und gerade am Ende, wenn der Abspann läuft, ist das einfach super schicke. Ja, aber der spielt die Musik dann nicht. Xavi Maas ist sozusagen ein Interpret. Der benutzt das Instrument. Der hat wahrscheinlich ausgesucht und zusammengestellt. Genau, das ist der von Brasil, schon ein bisschen älter. Ich habe ihn erst gar nicht erkannt. Ich wusste irgendwann, kennst du den? Kennst du den? Weil hier hat er jetzt noch keinen Bart. Im Film hat er natürlich so einen Bart und spielt so einen richtig alten Mann. Und ich habe irgendwie immer das Gefühl, den kennst du da irgendwo her. Und dann fiel mir erst ganz spät ein.
Okay, dann noch eine kurze Kurzfilm. Weiß ich nicht, ob ich es schon mal angebracht habe. The Fist of Jesus. Ein sehr geiler Bibelsplatter.
Ach das, ach das.
Das hast du letztes Mal schon auf der Liste. Das habe ich mir angeklickt.
Das ist ganz furchtbar.
Ich meine, Splatter ist eh furchtbar.
The Fist of Jesus. Ja, der ist wirklich, und drauf gestoßen bin ich, weil irgendwann gab es so einen Spielebundle, wo da war das Spiel dazu drin. Und ich dachte mir, was ist denn das für ein absurdes Spiel?
Also bei Splatter setze ich ja aus.
Gabelstaplerfahrer Klaus?
Das ist doch nur einmal witzig und dann irgendwie nicht mehr.
Ja, deswegen müssen es ja Kurzfilme sein.
Ja, aber gerade bei solchen langen Filmen, ich meine, wie lang ist der Film? Der ist auch lang.
Viertelstunde vielleicht.
Ach, das wird der ganze?
Ja, das ist der ganze Film.
Vielleicht haben sie auch noch einen langen.
Nee, nee, nee, der ist der Short Film. Der ist einfach großartig.
Also ja, es ist irgendwie lustig, aber ich kann dem auch irgendwie nur begrenzt was aufgeben.
Ich habe ihn nicht auf Anhieb durchgucken können, weil es mir auch zu viel wurde.
Ja, es ist einfach dann irgendwann echt zu mutsch, so.
Aber so dieses Ende, wo er dann mitten in dieser Verwüstung steht, das ist schon...
Ich habe noch eine Empfehlung für dich für deine Romance-Geschichte mit jungen Leuten. Und zwar Moonrise Kingdom, der ist auch super.
Ja, ich hatte nämlich auch noch... Also ich hatte auch noch zwei weitere, die, wenn wir gerade...
Die kommen ja nie raus....
Und der eine ist Flipped, heißt der, das ist so eine nette... auch Geschichte mit sozusagen, wo... ja, auch ein Mädchen und ein Junge irgendwie zusammen aus der Nachbarschaft, also von 2010 auch. Also 2010 war irgendwie offenbar so das Jahr der guten Romance-Filme. Und das interessante hier, man hat es auch öfter gegeben, dass halt immer dieselben Abschnitte einmal aus ihrer Sicht und aus seiner Sicht so wiedergegeben sind. Und dass halt auch im Laufe des Films sozusagen das Verhältnis so ein bisschen zwischen den beiden sich umdreht.
Da kann ich schon wieder kontern, Pavel. Da gibt es eine Serie, die heißt Sie ist fair. Und da lernen sich halt Mann und eine Frau kennen. Also er ist schon verheiratet, sie ist schon verheiratet. Und die haben halt irgendwann dann auch natürlich irgendwie vielleicht eine Affäre, vielleicht auch nicht, müsste halt die Serie gucken. Und man sieht immer die eine Hälfte der Folge, es ist ja so eine Stunde Folge, 45 Minuten, genau, die eine Hälfte sieht man das aus seiner Sicht, wie er sie gesehen hat, als sie sich zum ersten Mal kennengelernt hat. Und die zweite Hälfte der Folge ist das gleiche aus ihrer Sicht. Und als er sie zum Beispiel zum ersten Mal sieht in dem Diner, wo sie da arbeitet, sieht er sie halt so voll schick, voll so ein schickes Kostüm, relativ, der Rock ist relativ groß. So erinnert er sich und beschreibt er das, weil es ist so eine Rückerzähl-Story. Also die erzählen es sozusagen nach wirklich jemandem. Und er erzählt es halt so und man sieht es. Und während sie dann die gleiche Story erzählt, hat sie sowas gar nicht an und ihre Haare sind gar nicht offen und wild, sondern alles ganz normal. Und der Rock ist ein bisschen länger. Sie arbeiten das sozusagen optisch gleich so mit ein, wie die sich dran erinnern, wie es gewesen ist. Und er erzählt auch immer, naja, sie hat halt angefangen mit dem Flirten und überhaupt. Und sie sagten, naja, er hat irgendwie angefangen. Also schieben sich auch gegenseitig die Schuld zu werden, mit wem Cleas geflirtet hat. Und wenn man auf diese Feinheiten so achtet, also auch wenn er erzählt, ist seine Familie voll im Stress und seine Kinder machen voll den Alarm beim Deiner. Wenn sie sich erinnert, dann hat er voll die nette Frau und die Kinder waren voll niedlich und brav und alles war ganz ruhig und so. Und lauter so so'ne feinen Details.
Bei Flip ist es aber tatsächlich so, dass wirklich das völlig identisch ist, was passiert, nur dass die sagen, die Bewertung, was in ihr und was in ihm vorgeht und was sie gegenseitig glauben, das ist sozusagen... Okay, lass uns irgendwie jetzt... Also ich muss jetzt eine rauchen, meine Mate ist alle und...
Ja, deine Mate ist nicht da, wir können ja noch mal...
Mein Hintern tut weh und ich...
Nee, vom Sitzen hier.
Ich bin diese Stuhlform nicht gewohnt.
Deswegen leite ich jetzt hier mal das Ende. Ah, endlich. Genau, auch ohne Hucke und ohne Clemens lange Sendung. Wir danken fürs Zuhören. Super Gast und wir hören uns bald in zwei oder drei Wochen.